[Music]
he
n
[Music]
he
n
[Music]
I sit back with this bag
of what's
the what's the uh Splash damage um
warmine cell the splash for for solar
for Sol wrath
ofu WTH of
what's going on guys uh it's it's only
cost one no I'm not going to have my
camera on for this stream because I
promise will you can just take the game
play yes solar
armor any solar armor piece it only cost
one if you don't see it on the first
page uh scroll over to the second page
and um usually it's
there it's very cheap it only cost one
hey how's the clan going
La
your all right we going to
orbit I think that's a good one
90 I think that's a good
one 150 wish I'd had that years ago
180 y love it oh sorry
niceo couldn't have picked better
myself [__] my back
up
damn that's not
good make sure you bring in
zagis Bring It izy
bring it
Izzy
yeah
whisper yeah I'mma bring
sleep
xenop
sleep sleeper siming baby yeah I might
bring sleeper for that classic feel
don't forget you also use the The
Shining sphere Hera parent what about
her parent should we bring that I got it
just in case think is
crazy y have a good time I let y'all do
your thing no doubt i h y
back trying to bring all the
goodies them slow as
hell should we bring our eyes up
tomorrow I was thinking about
it
look it's good to have everything for
just in case some work
good I'm going bring sleepers s used to
be good in there remember yeah 8 and all
that
fall oh there it
went it's up y
s w on
y'all willhelm I I expect you to have
salvation grip to make our jumps
easier oh my God I'm going to be
terrible with those jumps all over here
we
go join us says VA the glass where
Mysteries
live in the deepest corner of the
available now for all
players oh I didn't press a that's why
yep I got the splash
screen I'm about
to 101 you're late Forte late a there
goes the world first oh we're
late we're not we're not getting jacket
Forte blew it that's it
Forte I'm not getting my jacket CU you
they beat out on the jacket right now
damn so Lord here you go
God
damn damn it 14 you did this to us you
what you say we could have had a belt we
had a belt there go the jacket there go
the ring oh my God bra jacket and belt
man you guys are ridiculous but I'll
join Forte out here fold in the world
first let me go with old
reliables yeah there he go then there
Legends oh my God two minutes oh they
got two challenge mod
okay both the glass you know looking
like challenge mode the first challenge
for challenge mode is you can you cannot
die okay so simple enough anybody who
gets world will have to do this entire
raid without dying oh wow that's I died
guys I died I died oh so they put it
Flawless after you get it done once you
have to do it twice so you have to get
through it to unlock challenge mode oh
no and my [__] just froze back back back
I'm back I'm choking I'm choking that's
all we all froze to second
you have to get through it once and then
you have to I spawned in dead I
spawned you sp
using play too much
right
stupid we died we all
died hit us right before we got in I'm
using bad juju oh here we
go not
really woo on my shoulders adct don't
know how to dress he don't know how to
dress like
meus let's get
it if the first part is exactly the same
as D1 I'll be happy but everything after
needs to be Chang the first run should
be about the same I expect Champions and
some craz maybe some Champions yeah I'm
going right I'm going Center I'm going
right far right far right right I'm
already right I already called it
to the
center dad Brother G so I guess I'm on
left where which one am I
going I see Taz at the Cent yeah I'll go
Center OH
w y didn't even let me rally a banner or
anything that's what I'm saying like we
got to go got to go we got to go we got
first time for that most likely we
probably [__] it
up all t i be my
fault I can't even get to my zone
nobody's with me on
left went left Co went left I assume he
was doing it in the
middle oh you got that death R oh yeah
that's what's up I respect that am Ro in
the r who died like
that I can't make it to my plate every
time I go to my plate I die what do you
mean I'm killing [__] why are you dying
gots and a uh one of those things they
hitting kind of hard out here well yeah
going that thank you said that's what we
going to do that's the time we on right
there like they hitting kind of hard out
here you need to take out that Cyclops
you see that Corte yeah that's what was
killing me the Cyclops it kept shooting
me over and over I didn't
even me Taz holding down in
something the Cyclops oh there go the
cyclop
got both dead on the
right get up screen I'm dead oh you just
got up I just
died just got a I'm trying to take out
the Cyclops yeah we got to work on these
cyclopses bro there we go those the
Jesus I'm getting stomped I'm me I'm
getting St Jesus do you already think
that we can hit that hard TR trying put
that
uh Shield up there we go you got
anything you can hit that hard
with I got you
sorry all right the Cyclops is dead got
a cyclops
again he is just one hitting me yo the
one hitting us yeah yeah and I'm getting
getting sniped from the Goin I feel like
we don't have enough I don't have void
you have void no I'm about to put void
on
yeah where's
my where's my all right this is the
round we got to hold it down all right
behind you get in front I've been
literally trying to get up here comes a
minitar snipers are annoying yeah the
the Cyclops is up again though
oh don't worry about the Cyclops don't
worry about the
cycl Cyclops is
out and cyclops killed me through the
wall I don't know
how
oh all right I put up a super up here
Forte so now have a little bit of a
b
and I got one shot by the Cyclops in my
super well that's
great try to take him out from
underneath he one shot me
again Cy uh does anybody have like a
they might need like a snipers or
something I don't know like CLS brutal
what it is someone's going to have to
have a heavy hitter to kill the Cyclops
right off the
bat
[Music]
yeah Cyclops is up here I might be able
to cover you from up here Cyclops
Cyclops is up good he shot
me I don't know where that heavy went
either
working put on a void weapon I don't
think they're doing [__] I doing
[__]
oh oh
damn super there God damn and they put
me the guy to kill that Cyclops and do
you have any heavy for him no no heavy I
throw a grenade on him though and he
shot
me damn why they put me so far Taz jez
am I don't
know D middle yeah there's a lot of them
up there right now I'm
lcls
up yeah I'mma shoot the deathbringer at
it
coming back up there but I think I'm
going to take a long
way s just just worry about that Cyclops
that Cyclops is killing us don't worry
about the menar all right just
communicate with me where the minotaurs
are all right I'm
back all right I'm clearing out the
plate putting the rift down there you
go drop more heavy and special all right
good
oh Jesus
Christ I'm going to try to just take
care of the Cyclops Cyclops I'm shooting
death Brer no
doubt God Like You focus on one thing
then the snipers get
CL is out I got an up just in case they
try to BM Rush
again never put up a
shield I'm having a hard time finding
team take an
up I don't feel like I'm getting any B
mine cells either weapon are you using I
was using uh like I should have be
getting plenty but somebody else sh
shooting at us God oh yeah somebody else
shot
shoot the one all the way on the left
[Music]
Savage he's
broken oh my
God doing everything I can to try to
kill that one
death are we making any progress no not
really
not I'm not getting like no heavy man
like none at all I'm getting nothing
getting no heavy I'm not getting like
none of these mods seems to be doing
anything like these grenade launcher
kills are not doing anything and I'm
using a Wither hord so I should be
getting like a significant amount you
going have to switch that with there's
too many heavy hits switching guns no
you got to swi you got to switch with
doesn't give you warind CS you got to
switch the weapon I'm not talking about
warind CS I'm talking about like all
the I'm getting plenty of Rocket ammo
over here
yeah I'm not having ammo
problem s we're both going to have to
stay on that side we're just going to
have to both hit that that Cyclops hard
oh I know was up let me yeah let me know
when that joint I had no idea that joint
was
up
how did the thing hit me when I'm out of
sight of
it clear some of this out all right
how's that that's good didn't we used to
cheese this by not being on the plate no
you uh
I'm pretty sure you have to be on the
play you have to be
on you don't have you just you just have
to be can't let them on the pl you don't
have to be on
the all Cyclops
up oh
thanks good
job you just can't let them touch the
plate yeah
yeah every time I go to put up a shield
man but isn't there a way can like get
them to just not go near the plate yo
what the hell push me
thanks just worry about that I got this
thing all right all where are you come
come this way I'm TR away from trying to
just just come this just come with this
way I will why is this so hard to hit I
find it's easier to get up here
ridiculous
and out of ammo they got us struggling
on the first
part they got us a
depress Cyclops
up every
time didn't we used to do the
three three three down here one on top
or three in the middle something we did
something different before yeah but it's
it's it's completely different when
you're completely under light
level i s man
like you can't keep dying
like oh [__] V
V keeps touching the goddamn PL
I mean I am getting nuked in my well I
don't know how much in the well you in
my well get
n like by just
like like random enemies like banging in
me Jesus Christ these snipers like is my
super
yeah I'm going to put that anti sniper
damage on from
distance I swear to God I can't do
it I'm D dying in my well I don't know
how to what to do with that maybe I need
to increase my
resilience you just you just got to be
in a part where that Cyclops can't hit
you as
easy no it's no no I'm I'm talking to
Sinister I'm talking to Sinister okay
sorry sorry
Cyclops has no respect for us every time
you say it name it kills
us you're just going to have to be able
to kill him in one hit cuz I I can't
switch off sword I can't kill him in one
hit he's too
strong let me
see come on I got stanked out the
air Jesus hold on I got you I got you I
don't doubt
let me get to the
place don't CL up even the Minotaur just
one hits me all cool yeah evenur oneit
well the minur they they have to hit me
three times but it's that [__] side
contest mode is a
mother have
any all right I'm getting that stupid
ass [__] yo what why is they I can
keep the Cyclops oh no Scout rifle got
to use a Scout rifle okay is shooting
me oh cops
up all right I'm I'm I'm I'm going
willhelm way with a hoorde not even see
and here's a weird thing I'm not even
getting Health back on my for my exotic
like well my I'm using the uh should I
should be getting Health back every time
I get a melee kill and I'm not it's not
giving you he
back I'm using the Titan stuff and I'm
standing in the um sun spots and it's
not giving me it yeah but if you're
taking more damage than it's giving you
it's probably going to look like it's
not giving you anything my health is
coming back really
slowly no
how are you still
alive we never go finish the raid we
going be stuck
outside the team that never made it in
the
team I think we do need I think we we
hold on we need to switch uh our our
roll cuz this this isn't working like I
think I think sin's right we need to do
three on each side and and one in the
back I two cuz you feel what is the
easiest side Forte is it easy up there
does it feel cuz I don't hear you
complaining said hell I'm over here
with oh that's an idea there we go what
that might have been what we missing
that might have been what we were
missing get them out quick there you go
get your out I guess I don't
know all
right know you can't use lit you have to
have something to kill the uh swords are
killing the that's what we needed I I've
been having swords oh okay down but the
thing is is both people can't use sword
because you're never going to kill that
cyclop I'm using with on yeah with I'm
going to
switch the bo got projecti yeah that
that's what I've been
using all right that was the first phase
we actually survived through yay pick me
up to
your I where are you Sinister like I'm I
told you I was
respecing I'm here now
I got
killed out
everything I
have heav over
there yo he didn't even shoot at me S
like come on man like seriously like I
said I'm Reviving you all the
time look at this this C has no Reon I I
told you like eight times to get in
spots where he can't shoot
you use the concrete so he he just
blasted me next to the concrete and I
could record
that shot CL behind
us
finally some War are you creating War M
cells yeah NOP okay good we need
everybody needs to be rocking warm
cells any shot this ccls
up I I just I can't do nothing S without
you like
down it's either I'm near the concrete
or where you at right
next I you kill the
Cyclops up get them
get one more wither it's
dead minut
coming T there we
go
wow
get this heavy all right I'm coming back
to you
now it is very
entertaining I got no heavy this that's
very
entertaining all you got a heavy okay no
heavy I finally got heavy I see it and
now I got no heavy y I'm
dead [__] y i before I can get to you
God damn we doing good
tooa okay yeah I'm just out I got killed
by middles I'm getting killed left by
middle Cyclops too that's why I think
I'm dying a lot we're getting shot I'm
getting shot by that other one from the
back he's not even up he's he's up now
watch out Cognito behind you
all right good look coming back up oh yo
who is sniping one shot sniping me whose
music is playing please mute yourself if
you got music
playing let's let's go with the music
man s you stay up there I'll stay up
here that way we could stop all these
ads from hitting us one sure put me put
me with all the bad guys oh okay okay
S I got a Flo I got the the thing is is
like I'm I'm yeah you know what I put on
wa
here there's two
goblins all right if I can stand right
here I can come on res I I put on the um
please like actually give me some health
tag Cyclops coming I mean a minitar
coming
down
they take the Cyclops down faster I put
killed by a cyclops
on still got
exposed you are
exposed out all right we're doing way
better S we're doing way
better all right down prion
here
heavy
oh [__] yeah they sniping [__]
Bro all right we got here
Forte when you respawn just wait for me
we got to go up together all right pan
minut
coming psyop shield
down
ammo right come up to this spot right
here pop your super pop got got him got
him
though super it's cool it's cool we're
good we're good we're good we're
good
[Music]
this two snipers on
top bottom got him I he killed me though
give me no heav first we need to get
that minur the minur is going to be is
the thing man they spawn me so far from
oh yes heavy it's okay it's okay I got
it I got
it the minitar is the thing
that's the Minotaur is the key and then
getting the
guy well we we I've been taking the
Minotaur out with the sword pretty easy
all right he's back up I'm going
over of the
Cyclops
oh
down all right Cyclops is down but I'm
weak behind the sniper oh [__] yeah get
the sniper oh
[__]
and
down you don't oh watch
out finally some [__] heavy
ammo all I'm going to put I got
snipers you're alone for a
second got an on the side
CL oh come on I got I was just about to
get you God
damn you almost back I
got I'm back I'm back they spawn me way
at begin way back yeah they be
disrespectful with the spawns bro need
your orbs or your blessing I don't think
I'm dropping any am I dropping any
orbs ah I got sniped there's a minur
down there
okay Jesus on on the bottom
side clear them oh my God they got
crazy
dead TI's down I'm coming I'm
coming I keep getting killed by middle
like what the [__] I feel like all the
minotaurs everywhere want to shoot top
left like if they if they don't see one
of you guys they immediately shoot I got
my super back about
to I got my supero or
Cyclops all right I'm going to propose
who's having the easiest
time one extra go top left at some point
yeah this [__]
crazy still no
Havey some
am got
sniped
S I don't have no heavy I'm going in
all I respawn don't worry about it all
right he one shot one shot
Dam I got to go through all the the
Beast that attic and them left to get to
the they left bad
beef I got killed by the Cyclops
again com almost
de man I just K there's just so many I
remember I just pop back in my head
remember we used to have people at the
halfways
instead yeah halfway in between um like
we used to have one person in the
middle and
then all right cool s you got to take
these ads I can't kill them
all I can't kill them all either I'm
[__] getting destroyed Cyclops n
Cyclops same where you are no
Cyclops got killed by the other
Cyclops I don't get killed by mine I get
killed by one of the others oh [__] this
prar still up taking care
ofs and he just sprayed me I can't even
get to the
plate I I can't even get to the
plate hey yall spawning in between me
and you take a minute for me to get up
here bro that's cool I'm just trying to
hold it
down all right I think we need to try
something
yeah yeah this isn't working like I
can't even get to the
plate I think sh was right though we
used to like TR to stay in the middle
between plates or something yeah but you
got to keep them off the plate charge it
what are you
doing oh I was switching stuff
up I'm going to I'm going to stay on the
left side
okay you have anything for the
side yeah mod
heavy down grenade launcher scavengers
not doing anything I'm going to stay
over here not doing anything prevent
them from coming up cuz you're better
with the
Cyclops we'll see how this go yeah come
on you can't get out of L all right s
I'm going to stay here and keep and keep
this door in
check I'm about to get overwhelmed cuz
the minur and the Cyclops is on the do
bottom side
if if you start to get over run just
yell out and I'll pull up all
right here they come
left one shot
inantly yeah I'm preventing them from
even coming up the the the ledge all
right oh you got to tell me the oh my
bad C I got was focusing stay right
there stay right oh [__] my bad my bad
I I'm back I'm back okay I
got I'm going to focus on this is this
this is what we did this is what we all
we got at y know something know as soon
y know the I just got killed from
Toops what happened y Noti that that the
minur hits the plate it spawns the
Cyclops yes so y' need to stop the
that's what I'm doing I'm I'm going to
the
when I'll take care of the Cyclops yeah
top side top side top side your votor I
mean your Cyclops all right coming
[__] oh you're down too oh you about to
take the
plate I'm going stay up not back Noe
that
[__]
he didn't touch the plate and the minute
and he was still
here you didn't touch
it all right I cleared it all right cool
I'm going to go back to my spot how we
was doing
it wait for them to spawn bottom side
just yell out when that Cyclops com you
tries to one shot me I
oh [__] who the hell he teleported in oh
he teleported yeah he W even know the
radar I got nothing to take out that
minur I got
it fing out all right no
doubt wor about the
pan wor about the pan Pan's down all
right cool yeah I'm help see this going
to help what I'm doing is help helping
foring them out cuz I'm preventing as
much pressure from getting to both of
our
sides Cyclops up again I'm just about to
turn to the Cyclops res me how did the
Cyclops get up again I don't
know it again I'm
dead
too nothing oh my God I
got pop your super pop your super
attic
coming what take got that side sniped
all right I got you Cyclops is
up oh [__] let me move yeah he going try
to one shot
me f all
right just go down there don't worry
about it here
I'm On Top oh we got a we
got on the right bottom fuele me my
damn I got you taking Dam saying
IM oh why is it saying immune
like
game it's down
Cyclops almost
down I ran out a shotgun
ammo up out not getting any War cells I
just
got minur bottom oh my God
man I got a fire on the Minotaur
minotaur's
down get back to that we don't want that
doing it yep pull up your speeder pull
out your speeder to get
there
[__] see now how did that uh get
up
no I'm handling how we we need you guys
we got we got this we had this side down
for a while we need you guys to pick it
up over there I got SN all I got
you
oh is up I don't have rer all right I'm
coming he's almost
down all he should be down now yeah get
that plate back up no doubt I'm going to
put an on the Sid to help
out oh yeahor on my side I'm
coming oh [__] I got
sniped I got you I'm going to stay right
there I got a rift on me if you oh you
down
too yeah he on the plate
damn there mad people on me though I
don't know if he want good oh yeah yeah
I'll just come I just come don't worry
it's just too many people all right guys
I'm going to jump out of the party and
good luck you guys hope you guys all
right bro I'm going to put super down in
the
middle oh my god there so much beef over
here
godamn this what it's loose the
plate oh you want to switch I feel free
you know it's loose it's Insanity over
here they spawn me so far back and then
when I got to get through y'all beef to
get the left and right's where the
majority of the ads are coming from all
when
I I'm almost
there soon as I spawn they spawn with M
Su
[__] oh my God
we had that [__] clear for a while we
had it clear
too Cyclops is
here all
right man
yeah Cyclops down new Cyclops is up
already yep oh that's a like we just
killed it yeah we just killed it I don't
got no heavy though all right got he
down
yo petarian
I got super all right he's down our
plate is
up where they at where they at some
heavy no heavy I clear out right side we
need something that takes out minars
fast at range the sword does what one
person in your team is going to have to
have the sword yeah and one person going
to does but we need a range
weapon I have no issue taking out the
menars it's the Cyclops that's why s
switched to the cyclopses something that
can do both I'm putting on a rocket
launcher Yeah
Boy Al I don't know up ring out all cool
might not
work my God pick me up when you can
after
[__] focus on the Minotaur it is
bottom if the doesn't get in there oh
the Minar can spawn it faster that's
what's the oh my God he just [__]
Laing got to go back up to the top [__]
they com play oh sniped that's what we
do send tell me when that menar shows up
menar top I got him though don't worry
about
him good
[__] oh oh [__] I got to go take care of
Cyclops I have no
heavy for I'm going to sit up here cuz
this is kind of what gets the cycle
going if I can stay up here and stay
alive he's one shot thank you clear the
and then you can take care of them it'll
at least and I
can so many of them
man oh my God that's
sh oh I was ready
you Cyclops back
up
regroup
what yes me
sh it didn't deactivate those then we're
okay a super Forte oh
the our bottom look look look look that
thing that thing is built like a
[__] right now
just got
folded oh I got hit by left side try the
try the Sleep uh the sleeping simul uh s
oh I was about to pick you up my bad my
bad let's go let's go it's go what you
call here Cyclops up y I don't have deer
every time I crack that Cyclops he
shoots like a triple thing
[__] you're about to take the plate but
I'm going to stay alive take
yeah oh they they haven't taken a plate
yet try the sleeping
simulate
snipers I'm
coming I
deactivated I froze those guys for
you you know what I think we're going to
have to go stasis yeah stasis is
amazing I'm I've been on stasis yeah
stasis is
amazing coming up on your
seats stops is up too God damn I got no
heavy and they running wild on the plate
yeah I'm about I got
got all right I F
onop yep no doubt
down down feel like I don't have any I
haven't had any ammo for this entire
thing
either I I have ammo it's just I go
through it so man we had we almost had
it built man it was almost done yeah we
were doing all right for a second and
then all of a sudden it's just like you
run out
of literally it had one more
left we just need to F focus on those
min minars those are the [__] s you
didn't tell me that the minitar was
there I'm going I'm going stasis I'm
going stasis oh stasis I'll tell you
it's good cuz you can control them a
bit slow field grenade all right let's
go mhm slow grenades
been all right cool I'm going to check
the other side left side let me see on
um
ad yeah that's a good spot scream cuz
they they love to sp there
I can
take try try the sleeping simul I don't
have to worry about the dam do we have
to still stand on it to keep it to form
it no you
don't this a good kind of a good spot
yeah if you can find a spot for the
minitar on that side I just helped you
out SC I can yeah yeah this is working
I'm just going back and forth with a my
my uh what this kind keep them from
coming out and they come towards me
anyway the problem with the eyes
tomorrow is you need so on the spawn
point so they don't get overrun you need
more I'm going I'm a freelance from both
sides oh you
got like there's a here
controller got an on
him sniper up
top
somewhere oh sniper hold on uh I'm on
the plate I'm on the plate I got you I
got you all
cooling
now don't have no heavy I swear he
dropped a bunch of heavy
bricks trying to help out Sinister and
attic
side yep here they come here come the
sniper oh the
sniper good [__] scream got that side of
the control so I'm I can help out more
on what your screen hold it
down I can't even get to the I don't
have no ammo let's go cyclop at all up
let me know when the Cyclops come up oh
he's up he's
up yo they keep [__] they destroying
me
down I'm helping on left side oh there
you are for PL all over
them miniatur bottom
side how's it going T is anything going
I need help on this all right I'm coming
all right I'm coming oh myen came back
he's going to kill me
yep I got
you might need a little help
here oh my God it's the [__] snipers
I see him I see him
yeah a
[__] God Dam they so disrespectful bro
right they are so
disrespectful we had it too
about to have my super in a couple
seconds it's Goins with this one shot
sniper
yeah it's like everything hurt I wish
this thing would give me some heavy ammo
that would be excellent you know on
occasion I got these guys from behind me
now coming over to me
spot he spawn
Cyclops I got heavy I got
am that's what's
up oh my God qu
us who think about having stag every
time I die
get that's the fly
[__] hell no oh [__] Splash D down
sniper okay I got you
shoot
bringer got on too
my see what's going on on this
side oh theyo I'm going to go help out
on oh my
God
all right I got I got no ammo at all
okay so you should be yeah
yeah all right for a
second that Cyclops s like got to have a
better way of killing that
Cyclops is up we shooting down at them
all right I'm coming PR oh
sh I don't have the Cyclops is gone it's
just well the problem is is when the
cyclop shows up you have to leave your
post to go kill him
like I'm scream is doing a good job on
that I'm right side the
brick scream at right side seem to be
the
problem scream if they if they over run
on the right left side just let me know
well the only reason for overun but I'll
let you it's just I'm keeping these I
like I like you
right I'm going to focus more on the
right side so this will help more on I
got you I got you yeah cuz I'm doing
what you're
doing I went Forte I went down briefly
there's one over there all right I'm
coming I'm coming yeah see when your sh
go down top I spawned up on top good
heavy ammo anytime would be
nice you back in business I'm back back
all right cool I'm going back to the
right T just let me know Cyclops
for and then we should this should be
this should be the flow screen cuz what
we're doing is going to help the
pressure on both of the other teams
thats
good
and then Taz is a beast getting out of
getting the Cyclops
outop is ridiculous
man I don't like try the S
simul all right
pan and I don't
have all right
cool is pan still acting stupid all
right he down minur over here what's
going on with your sh uh everything
pretty fine over here at the moment all
cool looking good looking
good the miniatur is next to the
Cyclops oh they put two they put goad
scen goad screen I see that
wait he all right I'm going back to the
other side side is clear I'm good you
got to rotate yeah you got to rotate
it's so many of them that you can't just
stay there oh you
got
shop about be up I have no all right
cool I got heavy when he comes
up I
am all right cool I'm doing my like what
is that the finisher move on so much
stuff I love it just all you can
do tering on the right side
working yeah what into that stasis
though what into that stasis how you
feel about that stasis though you don't
like
it yeah this is working this is working
left side all right cool super I got my
super I'm
coming they got some ammo down yeah Go
Get It Go Get It
got
cool how you doing over there Forte it's
back still don't
let's just both go hit it both go hit it
both oh orbs I need these orbs I just
died up top I'm coming back how's that
right side they looking over there I'm
okay good all right coming back we this
is good y'all we doing
good each side
oh I got
heavy
sniper scream how's your side oh
[__] okay
yeah coming over here pan
coming yeah there we
go he jumps I got he should be spawning
top side this time all right I'm going
to go right side cuz right side is about
to get
crazy how's your side screen um I'm I
died there all right I'm going to go
back over there to help out back yeah
I'm going to go back over there back
over going to get for it's it's actually
cool right now it's actually cool right
now I'm just trying to get back to we
got it's two it's two over
here I Frozen this down for
you good [__] beautiful beautiful
beautiful all right cool I'm coming you
got death okay
cool all right nice I'm going to check
over side house adct to
side you got to help them out they got
there they joint coming
nice all right I'm going screen what it
look
like are you kidding me
G about to be down the stupid War cell
didn't blow up that's all
right I got my my War M
cell almost there okay it's almost built
you guys it's almost built yeah scream I
need you over there we almost got I'm
coming I'm coming I'm coming I got I'm
holding it down all right cool I'm going
to go back to right
side have going my super here for you
you need it
back too
okay I'm not [__] around s I'm
helping you with that
[__] looking ass scream oh
Cyclops hmer you got heavy M bottom M
bottom
help thank
you nice looking good y'all we looking
good there done done done Jesus Christ
dude switching to stasis was the key
that was the key I was able to told that
stasis lit I was all that
bro I was able to slow them down just
enough that we were able to you know
move back and forth don't leave me you
have a handicap jumping
warlock
CH chest chest oh yeah hold on we
here there was never a chest oh rapid
Oracle disrup let me throw that on let
me throw that on I got something called
the rapid Oracle oh but I think it may
be let's see yeah I got to have you got
to have raid armor for that I don't have
no ra let me see let me see if it going
something else one
second it's
Arc Dam I a got
nothing got to have raid on it goes into
Arc yeah but the problem is you got to
have raid
[Music]
it's a ra yeah it's a ra mod for that
specific armor so I can't use it till I
get armor all right there's a dou before
you go down chest right here somewhere
right where's the chest at oh [__]
remember the secret chest yeah
right it's yeah you have to jump
underneath I don't know if it's still
here but this is
away the trial of kabar I don't know
where I went I don't y'all didn't do it
y'all not going the secret pathway I
don't know where yall went I did I am
everybody left me I don't know where
yall at I remember it's dark as
hell oh I remember this yep I remember
this
too oh [__] where the hell did you go
will oh there you go
Okay jump down yeah I don't remember how
to get over there how you get over there
they just let jump down and
back down that way supposed
I don't know I don't remember they left
they didn't even jump back and down back
and down where do you go from here s
it's down right is over there yeah like
over there that way do we go let's just
go the real the reg almost there they're
they're I remember the yeah the chest is
right here I found it where I found it
it's right here next to me go back and
get them go get back and get them I
won't open it yeah come back ad let's
let go wait to open it cuz I want to the
chest all right we at the part where you
jump somebody come back to get us guys
secret chest be sure to s or wilhelms
memory I I don't know y coming back to
get us Forte go get them I don't think
they could climb can y climb back up I
can't climb
back go back you don't need to climb up
just come this way just come around the
corner you don't need to climb up just
come here see where you how about you
guys just look at my stream and tell me
where to go we're talking about all
right go
get how about you just look at my stream
and tell me where to go say start it
says starting soon no I did that I did
that so so back up a little so I can see
where you at all right up there right
right there jump down no no go back I
it's it's delayed you're just going to
have to you have to you have to so that
right hand corner the right hand side I
mean the left hand side sorry the left
hand side go to the left hand
side
MH he's going back and forth on my
screen hold on I'm waiting for it the
left hand Edge the left hand
Edge no not there not there not there go
up top go up top I I don't from up top
the left hand Edge you got to it's like
a 5 second delay okay turn around turn
around and then jump into like you're
going to jump off backwards but you're
going to fall into the Rocks into the
wall below you there's an entrance so
jump off back about to die
look he's dead not to charg it I can my
room from the left side not from the
right side from
the
top what you need my phone
for I'm almost going to die so that no
that was the wrong one that was the
wrong one you're supposed to do it from
the other side I'm just going on like I
I have no idea where you're talking
about like not even the it's above you
to the left but you you got to
understand I'm on a delay like you're
talking about 10 10 15 seconds
behind all right so it's this side they
said jump off yeah just die yeah get up
top on top the left hand Edge the left
hand Edge fall off I see I see it I see
it it's surprising cuz me and adct used
to do this all the time I just it's been
years since I did it like
years years for me too okay like your
point you have a better memory than me
like oh there you go there go for no it
was will I was I was going to run past
this and Will was like where's the you
remember this right here follow follow
him follow uh adct watch it
okay oh addict's right next to me never
mind all right now remember you go
around to the ra spoils I keep get mods
anything else got got a mod
too down go around this and then
in you will get armor eventually but you
have to complete it first once just like
the a deep Stone CP
okay oh can we Thunder crash
across where yall went yeah oh this is
the room the Templar
room oh God this is going to be even
worse
right
here you rally the banner here as
well wait wait wait what what goes on
here this is the Oracle clear add
control Right add control orbs so we
need Anarchy is not going to be good for
this no is not going to be good here
nope yeah was it sleeper really good
here you used to one shot the
orbs this is Oracle B this right yeah
the Oracle we used to one shot the or
I'm going to use Zeno cuz Zeno we change
up yeah we're going to need some long
range long range hard hitting I remember
long range hard
hitting we just got to remember when we
see the lights you remember the
positions we used to stand um adct
remember we used to have we used to have
two two guys here hold on let me out the
Vault them two one in the middle back
right no two two well we had one in the
middle for the beginning part for the
end part we had to move him we had to
move him back to the
middle because it was easy in the
beginning give me a second I got to pull
out sleep my dam if I who who's rocking
long range right
now
[__] you should take left cuz remember
they got that the problem with with the
the of Tomorrow is you had to be more
diverse like you had to be able to take
out
the the cyclopses and the menars and
there's only five bullets that's why I
switched with the kept the sword both
sides have
snipers yeah both there's a sniper that
spawns over there and on that right and
then there's one that spawns on these so
y yall don't want me to use long range
weapons you could if you want at if
you're going left so he's going
left and who's left is just me and
CZ we'll be middle so that we help each
other is everyone here you going you
going right everybody
here I wonder cuz we got that Shield
remember there's going to be a shield
one one person has to run the shield in
the
middle all right well you don't do that
here you got this is the first part it's
just add clear and add clear add clear
oracles right all right look you want to
jump
down yeah fight y ready yeah I'm ready
no no no oh wait he not ready ready for
already jumped off they jumped down
already they jum
down a test run while we
waiting there's there he is look at
there he is there he is I don't want
nothing to do with that
smoke go left cognito you were going
left right
oh I'm with you
c yeah take
middle 14 WS on the right all right we
got
it got a wavers we this pretty clear W
are here they got wyers
yeah oh [__] oh yeah
bastard champion
at damn that dude didn't give two shits
what I was
about
damage secret spot you think the secret
spot works again
downstairs remember the secret down
remember they probably patch that stuff
on I'm down I need a oh me
and can't Beed I got no oh we on red
tokens I got token so me where do we CLE
in the middle the middle in the middle
yeah oh God I died
shit' shoot I don't know I didn't see
anything on the
ground overload Minar overload
overlo need overlo weapons
B he went down with no
problem where we get oracles
right nobody got a res for left side
anybody it's right man we might as just
go white this was a broken run
anyway
that's why we're going to do it yeah I
know right it will be a half ass win
half ass
win that war mine cell do something w we
got a w marked again I'm going to go
help them with the
wyvern here com to
wver God damn it I'm dead again yo Xeno
Fage is the way to go man this should
it's taking ticks off of him even know
he destroyed
me guys are just wasting time man we
should have wiped them what you 10
minutes ago what the sniper for what the
boss what are you Us in
Xeno
W I think he about the
overload Eric M says this is why you
should stay together during raids keep
the same raid team
was pumping lead into that guy into the
into the wyvern into wyverns yeah all
right let me pull it out of
um stasis was slowing them down but I
love stasis in this whole race so far
but we need overload so I think yeah I
don't have any overlo start I have
overload I have overload you got
overload who's on the left side should I
put overload on as well should hold up
do you
do you think I should put on uh Divinity
I need over like one second oh I put the
voral one on the you think I should put
Divinity call while you trying I'm going
to try I know I'm I'm G actually try
what I could run and then run up to the
things that make them weak if want just
to see how we got to see what's an issue
first y want me to run should have to do
that as long as you don't you have the
mod where if you use a grenade launcher
on it it it some
anyway you don't need again and that
that does it automatically every 10
seconds so
Anarchy whatever so using Anarchy
Anarchy got that buff too
yeah yeah give me one second y'all Dam
AC can
St
okay breaching clearers for what
um class
it
class
scaven
you what's better boss or major spec
always forget major maor until we
shooting the boss
then
Alles I don't know if it's like yellow
bars or above only bosses and Y got
overload on the left
side I didn't even see
him Forte
said we should have one more though just
in case I one I you got overload who's
on the left side with me overload that's
me me I have it add it add the left side
do you have I have overload submachine
gun I have
overload on the left side
though oh I've been muted this whole
time um I have overload for machine
gun uh switch to um
Anarchy
so let's give if you have it I if you
have it I do you think I should switch
it to V
no I mean what purpose cuz the champion
for the boss damage Champion I I got I
think that's a pH though isn't it that's
phe so how is it working for you
Taz I just equipped it so I'm just going
to use it for my overload but I'm using
the last impress rocket so all right I'm
going to see how well we stun them with
this machine gun all right here let me
know how it is what machine gun you
using that got overload
no it's the
mod overload submachine gun that's the
mod oh submachine gun oh I'm like what
machine gun is that okay you use it uh
what you call it I know what you use it
all right whatever you got
ready I'm ready now all right cool I'm
scared I'm scared here we
go I'm right behind you at
it
ler
oh it pushed me off the
map it just pushed me backwards out off
s i here jerk in the wck it spawned me
and then it just threw me off the map
like on spawn that's not even right just
feel like a lot of excuses man sh in the
r hey who needs to be cleansed
somebody needs to be cleansed you go to
Middle
remember oh middle that wver running
loose getting overr on the left all
right I'm coming I killed them all with
the
one
oh that that get out of there that
Templar is going to [__] you up I know I
know I'm trying to I just trying to save
you
first overload
mle oh I got one shot what the
H that's the boss the boss did that to
you that was a hob
go for ter okay good [__] oh I don't got
no
ammo I never gra you
go whoever needs to get cleansed The
Middle's
open Mark for
neaton yep thank you
cleansed left side's building left
side's good I'm closing off the
middle I'm going go get them orbs y got
on the left yo you put mad bricks down
that look wow
fny you
stup anybody need
cleansing there's no white stuff inid
wver on the left wer on the left all
right
coming
oh my God he's taking a lot of dam oh my
God I'm down that I need to
get R like crazy I got Ked I got killed
sorry it's a w we're going to have to
all come together for that waiver what
it is is is one person on the I'm going
back the one person on the middle is
going to have to help whatever side the
waiver pops up because Cog was doing
crazy damage to him he can give two
shits like mhm no but what I realized
what I
realized [__] so I'm taking that off I'm
switching I'm switching to Divinity I'm
switching to Divinity okay back me
shooting that wavering should help with
that yeah and then if you do that and
then I'll put the uh the Trap I'm not
even using that submachine gun I was
using the shotgun and the sword
more give me one second before we start
thank you for letting me rally this
time dudes start it you ready
go hit here go one
second not started
yet
you ready
go I'm ready hold up not yet not yet not
yet problem want here here
go let's put Auto rifle savager on so I
can get PL kick step
T ready
you see how they just say ready and they
jump they don't I was the only one I was
the only one that haven't done it yet
yeah when I turned around they were my
bad we little thirsty IIT IIT I was
excited excited my fault hey hey I
remember the spot will this is the spot
right [__] we used to just stand up here
and
and oh right there yeah
go more to the left go more to the
left oh God the oh Lord I got
you I got y go get
that got a waiver in in the middle oh
God that
waiver Co help them with that
waiver I think we need to restart we got
too many deaths death why are we dying
so
much we set off a chain
reaction you're not going out like that
for what time you going to waste time
okay yo clear the whole joint baby you
got it you remember you used to it
oh wow can we still come up to the
top well there's that one side on the
other side you can get up on top of that
one
pillar here on
the on the left side you what I'm
talking about we used to shoot the all
the oracles from the top they patched
that in
D1 they patched that yeah they patched
D1
what old
hustles but you guys see what I'm
talking about right I know I know which
one it's that one over there yeah that
one there that one right there you can
get up on top we used to climb up
there all right you guys ready y okay
everybody's ready all right let's
go I hope so well I mean speak up or
shut up like damn like we asked three
times then we jump off when you didn't
say nothing being a smart ass over there
acting like you trying to be
slck
Focus yeah move up Sir Tas or like right
here yeah right here move up oh my God
all the snipers maybe you should have
moved
up
behave I got him we're probably going to
goad and need to this white we already
lost a
life clean let's get a little practice
in get practice let's get our Banner
let's get our banners work of action
yeah baby get a little test
pop a few supers get a little risky you
never know what can happen you said get
up
that he jumped over my an smack
me I Ain going that was funny I got to
respect
that I forgot that they could jump he's
like
yeah people are going to have to be very
vocal where those those things are man I
didn't even know that was in the middle
like you're not dealing with the waav
and [__]
like sitting there dealing with the VES
and you going to be like are you dead
like it was some harpies and you act
like
oh we should for to the middle
we to say the words get you're taking
the right side but like my thing with
you my thing with you Forte is you're
wasting time right now like this is a
guaranteed loss and you guys are wasting
time in the
middle so strong we need to put him in
the
middle I SAR for is so strong we need to
put him in the
middle go to the right I can stay in the
middle I'll stay in the middle I have
Anarchy no we want for want for that we
want forte in the
middle youy to
for that
midd yeah is we set up for a lot
of will go to the middle and and the
weakling go to
the stay over there come over
there he in a suburban area it's not get
over
there it's not hot
enough go to the right side where no no
no no no stop trying to look you're
trying to live off a will Helm's cotel
so get up
off like yo I'm
alive I don't know what's going on with
Y and he's wasting mad
time they got to
go but but citizen don't respect that
hood over there cuz I'm over here
helping them and stuff like he don't
realize I'm on their side middle when
there's nothing on my side here we got
to focus we got to focus y'all making me
laugh stop
it
he's scared to death he's scared to
death in a
minute the wavering the waver here they
out here side
shaving here here there you go help oh
my
God I already had him killed don't
coming up in here late he already a
pitch of he dude dude like you know
what's funny like Forte tried to watch
the end of the movie he said he watched
the whole movie
like he try act like he big dog out here
man man I came over there and put my
sword to his chest all right left side
get
crazy just pull back a little bit pull
back a little
bit probably help them
more midle overload in the middle I can
like cover this whole get that uh Co
I'll get
this this whole I'm out of ammo I got
freaking Mark I'm out of
ammo you going to come
back about to get our side look
crazy I marked I marked I
marked yeah all right we got
the on the right side I marked too and I
didn't get a chance of get I didn't see
where to
go
whoa that's a glitch who needs to
cleanse I got hit by the boss I
got right there we go oh
[__] all right waiver is up what side
left waiver on left right side right
side W on right side
oh we're on our own call yeah look
at oh my
God I'm down that
wer up like he was a cook anarch pretty
good Anarchy build seems to be pretty
good as far as versatility goes sword
here it it kills the waiver pretty quick
and let you stay SW give me a second
like okay here here here's Here's my
thought process all right when the
waiver that time there was two waav one
on the left and one on the right like
the two people in the middle are going
to have to help each side like
I responds whenever the conf whatever
side the conflex is on is where R comes
from okay you have to F all three sides
the the first is in the middle second's
on the right third's on the left don't
start it changing this
Jo all right jump
off for
yourp yo how we used to two Twan this
thing a contest
mod the contest B is real that's what it
is got I'm over here sweating got some
deodor
I need ammo all right Willam said
everybody put
on well I don't know favorite weapon
with the Anarchy Anarchy seems to be
pretty versatile and it was doing well
against the wav for yeah for me it feel
like it wasn't though yeah but the sword
I'm doing so much more damage with the
damage yeah that's what I saw he doing
with that sword I'm taking out like five
six mobs at the same time
one
it also lets you uh not have to worry
about Focus like it also lets you not
have to focus the um the ads you can
just sort of lay a trap and focus the
waiver but I don't know if that's good
for maybe just like every group might
want to have like one ad
clear you know like one major ad clear
Guy what's that ktic um he said is it
wavs or
wyverns is it wavs or wyverns I think
it's where you're
from if you're from the south it's wavs
if you're from the north it's
wyvern next question man
is next question man is can I block you
or can I not block
you oh my God this thing is so slow well
since y doing that I'm going to go use
the rest real quick yeah go for it I
just got to
go
Rush found it
okay [__] godam yeah go for
it sounds like get that oh man this
Vault class is about to get murdered I
see people on Final encounter
already already them already on the
final
I'm glad it's back though
yeah yeah but it as long as we get day
one we'd be
happy finish it and challenge mode is
off we going out and coming back in so
we don't have to do
ch
oh yeah Forte when are you going to
start doing the uh your prediction uh
videos you went to the
bathroom Oh I thought that was s that
went to the
bathroom cuz I was thinking it's about
that time to start those prediction
videos think I might do it like the
beginning of next week something like
that
and you're probably not this week but
the following week being KY probably
have some kind of prediction show too so
prediction yeah what do you do a
predictions
E3 you could tell you don't do like you
could tell you do Destiny what what's
what's going
on shut out the
screen
I think I might put death ringer on to
be honest for the middle for the middle
chaos yeah me do be kills yeah I'm
running I'm running is that
anarchy it's there but to be honest with
you what for death death I think I'm
going to keep with my sword though I
don't know man getting up close to those
those wyverns or waver I don't know what
this dude in the chat wants me to refer
to the
mask
getting close to those things with my
sword I get really like anxiety like I
think cuz those things just turn around
like what are you
doing you asking
me huh you was asking me no I I was
saying those wyverns was say what are
you doing and just
smack they don't
care he don't
miss
I got that
one everyone back I think so well I
didn't hear Forte
yet
all right I changed everything up for
the
rockets doing your rocket agent
ordinance is
on I'm actually trying to just if
something's working a little bit like
I'm taking my ADD clear ability as a
sign that it's working okay for now I'm
just going to try to become even if it's
not the best I'm going to try to become
a little bit more proficient with it so
that I fig F out what is working then
I'll switch to it who's doing middle
good with all the
mechanics s listen list me and you
switch and the reason I say me and you
switch is cuz Taz and me are using uh
divinities so what we what uh so when
the waverings and stuff spawn on each
side me and him could split up with the
divinities and the two people on the
side can can do damage while we make him
more
we I don't care yeah so I'll do middle
I remember back in the day able to do
all all
sides I mean I can still stay on left
it's it's just going to be a little bit
of memory jargon and then we should be
back in it I can stay on the left he
cool you didn't stay on the left yeah
I
you okay come on let it out let it
out now go get some
water go get some water for
T aont has just got to uh the place
where where we were at yeah
nice yeah we're pretty much where
everybody
is except for the try hards except for
except for glad
glad shout out to
GL you know what's probably funny they
were probably under leveling the hell
out of themselves doing the raid on
[Music]
D1 people doing people we're doing good
practice runs but I I wasn't I wasn't
playing at that 30 frames nonsense yeah
I can't bro same thing I say that 30 FR
where is for like man like he was
choking give him a minute that that was
me that wasn't him choking that was me
oh that was you oh wow that sound like
his kind of choke for get some water
adct now we still waiting waiting on
Forte Forte had to do number two you
know yeah he said you know what while
I'm
here I feel it I respect maybe you got
the endless white yo I'm done can we
push him off so we can all die real
quick so I go rally the banner I changed
the Rockets you guys remember where the
secret room is over there too right yeah
get ready to push them off I'm going to
start it get ready to push them off
yeah uh on you jump in the wall I got
join get the secret
chest
I don't push him off push him off yo it
just got me joining allies down at the
bottom it's fine we just need to Die
Another another raid Banner wasted no no
s ask us to do it he needed a right ban
oh oh okay you remember there was an
edge to stand on up
here yeah that edge is not there they
smoothed it
out but I'm sure that thing is open we
can get all the way to the left too I'm
still over here trying to figure out
like how Forte
has Forte uh oh uh
oh
eled I got removed I'm still over here
trying to figure out how Forte has a
certain
callers well when you play with somebody
so so long you know they he's got he's
got that that cough cough or he just got
that cough like cuz I I'm curious what
you got the same cough we got the same
cough okay I I don't know man I feel
like that's a little suspect you got
your Xbox in white
ew I just saw your dashboard that was
disgusting I'm tired of you color
shaming stuff man like I don't
understand no it's not just sin what is
wrong with people judging if you have
your Stu like first off you got a white
dashboard though oh my God
I I feel like like I get it black Dash
boards don't matter to you here we go
black Dash look look look look no no
look
look see when it turns when I no no no
let me talk I have it set to wherever
time of the day that's what color my
stuff is at night it's black at the day
it's light this is Classic this
is guys are ridicul jump over that
corner over there mhm I got him turning
whe can I go see if I can do that real
quick oh and go all the way around Forte
I me for will we're not trying to glitch
The Raid okay we try to do the raid
we're try to glitch The Raid speak to
speak for yourself well you could do
that on your own
time no you're supposed to jump to that
first I must have G the wrong way you
got you're supposed to jump over here
first like a ledge there's I got a turn
back barrier
anyway it was like a ledge up there that
you able to jump you can't do it until
after you start it you have to run
through that section to do it and I'm
not going to start
it I'm sure you can make it cuz you
could Thunder crash over there oh I
could go solar Go Solar absorb your your
grenade and jump you know what's great
is I can feel like I can see a lot
better and you're forgetting a a crucial
step will you're forgetting you were
supposed to come over here I'm going go
mute I don't know I'm going to go mute
for a couple minutes while I'm going to
talk to the chat so just hit me when you
guys got the chat open
here are y'all dead again yeah it's that
look up look look okay first
off over here are you dead again this
isn't as easy as it looks all right
ledge D sh oh there's a whole area up
there now back all right the thing is
the thing is is is when it comes to this
I know I know I I see it when it comes
to this like it might look easy but
these things will kill you in one or two
shots like and it doesn't matter what
level you are because they they cap
you they always make sure that you're
weaker than who you're fighting oh you
got what are you serious start
it wear will with his his his glitching
ass will with his glitching
ass Taz Taz you Taz you Taz you let that
man take the fall man you know what Taz
I got to respect you because no no hold
up Taz I got to respect you because if
that was me if that was me I would have
let him take the blame I would have let
him take the blame I was watching was
like I'm about to end this whole ra I
thought it was
pretty by myself she needs to open that
door it is way
too I got I got to hand that to you Taz
if that would have me I would I would
have I would have kept my mouth shut I'm
like yeah it was well I saw I saw I had
the truth that's all I needed oh no no
he's he was quoting us like why I kept
telling sin to sto dying in the last
part he was quoting us I pay attention I
go Ah that's pretty good no he was
quoting Forte that's who he was quoting
when Forte kep say y'all dead
again oh yeah for Forte when uh question
Forte when are you doing your prediction
videos all right let's go let's go
put the ra
B
yeah yeah that's what I'm going to do
mine
too I once used that as a background in
a student film that I did and everyone
was like where did you get this I'm like
I made
it someone was like I think that's
cowboy bbop and I'm like shh
you getting a little too friendly with
that Templar he ain't trying to take you
out to dinner
man waiver in
Middle
coming all right I got the
uh oh yeah lament baby oh yeah it's much
better I got kill but it's much
better but it's dangerous but you will
do Dam someone come revive him I don't
have a a thing you died earlier at
yeah my fault oh it's fine that's be
messing up I was I was being extra
aggressive I'm testing stuff out but my
mess up there so many people this my
mess up y that that that was my fault I
I I died being a dumb ass I was so
excited that was like the liit was doing
what it was supposed to do that I was
getting too Co CO's going to need help
uh just white we's too many we lost too
many people just
white yeah this a
white
again I really want to test this Anarchy
against I hold it down by myself over
here I got left and middle I got left in
middle that czy I got to ccle
between I'm done with put stats on
my on me I need
Buffs did they cross play on more dots
more dots more dots I need more dots dot
ridiculous you're crazy everyone run to
the center whatever you I demand I
demand a
recount all right let's get this down
let's get this
down s grab it grab it grab it I didn't
grab the
ban who broke their legs I did I was
looking at sin hoping trying to get him
to grab the banner and I didn't click a
to there was no Banner it was gone
already yeah I don't know what she was
doing but it wasn't grabbing the banner
that's for
sure I'm might have to blame that one on
sin sin should have had that b always
blame me always blame
me it's fine I'll take the blame I mean
I didn't ask for your permission of
blame middle
okay he's going to get that blame
regardless he runs out yeah that's what
we're going to have to do my God that
middle
crazy I got him I got him no too many
deaths too many
deaths one person died too many deaths
one person resulted in two people dying
a't that's crazy
all
right I'm hurt Cog I'm
hurt oh I marked where where do I go
from if I marked Center Center Center
the middle the
middle run to the center it's not there
yeah it's there now it's there now it's
there now it just disappeared oh no no
okay there there there no it's gone it's
gone like I still have
it he must have hit another thing you
hit another patch on the ground you hit
that green stuff man no I I I didn't
like someone picked it up right before I
picked it
up I'm coming to I'm about to die
someone needs to reev revive
me I don't I can't I don't have anything
more to pick you
up
wver
left wver left yeah not me I'm going to
Super just white just white oh Forte how
that wyvern going over there for you man
easy right easy right a breeze what's
going
on it seems like it seems like that's
seems like that Wun shows up on each
side regardless after you do that cuz
that's the second time that's happen
middle looks like both sides middle yeah
so like I said like uh when that second
wave hits um Taz go over there with the
Divinity and hit the right side yeah
that's what I've been you mean left left
left no I'm on left I'm on left I have
Divinity oh yeah okay yeah I
go right we just got to stop dying for
dumb [__]
S I was alive at the end there you were
dead Okay me and Will was the only two
last ones alive okay all right all
right where were you Mr I had I we had
waste look man you just you just need
need to mind your business all
right mind your business
waiver in
Middle popping my super to kill
him all right now there should be a
waver right and
left
not yet that wa the wav shows up when uh
it it clicks again all right somebody is
needs to be
cbody need if
anybody's marked enemies watch for the
green watch for the green boys overload
in the
middle overload he he's like stepping on
a little
step oh that was a clean little B shot
all right here they come they'll be on
both
sides how we looking how we looking how
we
looking if you need help call it
out got Rivals and
Co that well-placed
grenade M I'm up here man I'm I'm
waiting for this wyvern where is he
waver and wyvern I don't care what the
chat says
oh man on the middle they over here yeah
it's good right now oh wver wver I going
help with the wyver shooting the rocket
help
on I'll shoot another one if you need it
dead on the left I mean on the
right left side yall good yeah yeah yeah
we're good we're good I got him y on
that Divinity yeah that Divinity helped
did we I think we two manned did you
help
s i y okay it was being T Taz put down
and then we did
it I had the
Divinity there really wasn't much in the
middle so me and T like went to both
sides at the same time no that's what I
meant that's what I was saying like uh
that during that time cuz if we could
kill him quick enough you'll get back to
your post quick enough damn there's like
eight blocks of heavy got a waiver on
the left side on the left side left side
okay yeah yeah I see him all right get
ready I see one on the right throwing a
rocket oh I died I died I died all right
I got you will you get the rest the
closest to me for is the closest to
me got him thank you
Forte I put some debris in the did we at
least get the W I don't
know w
oh we got an Unstoppable boys oh for
real Unstoppable on the left side
overload I got sniped by your guy I want
to go help there's a guy on your steps
behind you we got him we got him we got
him there's a sniper on your steps that
was a surprise midd the
middle I need a res oh I got I got it I
got
it Chaz got me
got ritual of negation anybody need to
Cleansing I already did mine
no keep that grenade in the middle some
ammo me whoa what hit
me me you're uh doing pretty good
holding this car mhm
I'm marked I'm marked Dam go just go oh
man I I got a res I'll jump over I got
him I got him oh you got him yeah thanks
wyvern wyvern wver Center wyvern left
wyvern
on oh I got killed again I got Ned by
it by the way I was able to get a couple
of things on him oh
damn said they said three at one time
yeah I killed I killed ours but they got
us yeah they said three at one
time I think that was the last one that
was probably the last year Forte how are
you doing with the DPS on uh call do you
think what do you think about what do
you with the
sword what you what are you using for uh
to hit the wyvern so is yeah I'm am I
help are you just popping a super is
that
all I'm using Anarchy and about to go
back toarch bu with grenade launchers to
go back to Anarchy cuz it's it's the
sword is just too risky it does the
damage but it puts you too much in the
mix hold one second take what about the
sleep what do you think that would
do I mean I could try it I mean I give
it a [__] second I mean do the Anarchy
because it'll be constant damage I'll do
it but it'll be good because when they
pop up from
far when it's if Taz yall do Divinity
yeah I'm going to give that a shot give
me a
second who out here
cooking
my
wife always be that
noise cooking that good good all right
let's do that I'm surprised s hasn't
jumped off
yet jumped off what here's take take the
magical Axe and just jump off the
map I'm too cool for that there ready
one second one
second
one second
guys I really want to put on with
a go ahead now what whatever you doing
is working Oh I thought I thought I had
him for a second oh stupid
ledge it was a
failure all ready everyone here I don't
know yeah you start it start
all for you ready ready everyone ready
okay
clear I switch to all reliable what you
switch
to with
wether n anti barrier I got put because
them
damn
them snipers when they curl up
they oh I'm dead I didn't even notice
those over there come get me
call where you oh damn they put you all
the way over
here
Jesus y got that sensor
wver yeah my's
down oh I I'm I'm I'm
marked me
too oh no more thing oh my God I died
just wi just wi we've had too many Des
why why you always
must we a go see and act like you didn't
die like a billion times in the first
area left side's rough it was my me
it was me but I I don't mind taking the
blame cuz I know it was my fault unlike
Sinister so unless some
is just jump
off I'm over here playing music being
shot
at
Swap you need a little bit more AC me me
and Forte are doing a lot of AC it's f
just one it was just one run me and Cog
were doing fine last time after we kill
our wurn look back for one second and
see if if we don't have a pillar we can
split you go left I go right and we make
sure they don't die as soon as we kill
the Wy that that over look at those look
at those people at the top of the list
let's
go I like two minutes ago
bro
everybody get the uh thing BBY yeah yeah
yeah you
ready my
father man with the DPS like what are
they trying to pull here you know that
man that has all that DPS over there in
Sinister you know he over there letting
Taz carry
him uh I'm freezing them while he's
shooting get that work in man man the
Sinister I know should be able to freeze
and kill
them
right I'm not even a fall out there's a
waiver cuz it's dead
already well good bring bring that DPS
ass over here bugman are already
dead left y'all looking good over there
mhm hey Taz our thing is gone we can go
help them on the right and
left watching
left everybody need to be cleansed you
see how right this right side was so
clean Sinister when you came over
here I was just tricking him so I can
have the bu of myself I have one bad run
people want to act like I've had bad run
every time
overload in the middle overload in the
middle behind
you I got you I got y'all there you
go you know what don't call me when you
got a wiper don't
call don't call out I don't want no call
beef is
this I'm grabbing orbs hold
on
I'm
choking why you always dying Sinister
what's going on over
there oh God oh God here they come uhhuh
on the right on the right M oh do you
calling for help
now I got you I got you here comes my
bullets oh yeah Is What It
Is Here Comes My Bullets you saw how
easy that was to take down okay we're
not going to act like C's sleeper had
nothing to do with that my sleeper was
what it
do here check if y'all Mar look at look
at how clean that right side
is look at Sinister trying to take
everyone's
homework well I got mad rockets on the
floor so I'm just shooting my rocket in
every direction
oh got uh uhoh uhoh you need me you need
me here comes my
Rockets my Rockets do the business you
see that you ain't got to worry about
[__] oh Dam oh yeah we down now our left
side is down oh oh what
happened we were fighting a wyver we
were fighting a wyver by
ourselves you need help over here let's
go
throwing a little help over
there got another I'm not liking all
this we
got overload someone's got to come get
me where you at oh they push you all the
way up there I got you
got all the way no that that that's
where I go when I'm shooting him with
the Divinity cuz he can't shoot me oh yo
there overload on the left on the
left you see it left
I don't see
him I came over here I don't see
him he's there I got him I got I got
he's in the corner he's a
ninja keeping it clean keeping it
clean oh I went down I went we have
aill we have a pillar we have to defend
all
right
oh yeah I was getting I was getting
wyvern on the right I was get in the
middle I don't have anything for add to
help
him yeah left side's
down Middle's almost down he down yeah
the we're coming right side the Templar
killed I'm out of heavy ammo out regular
ammo out of Special ammo
there you go and we cleared right side
left side left side I went down again
now just we just cleared
them it said the Templar prep yeah it's
at the temp look at all that clear look
at all that
clear it's a beautiful clear right there
and everybody keeps say y'all ain't got
three WS three wns for cister record
that
everybody yeah I tried it it's good just
wild but you got to hit the crit life if
you don't hit the crit then it's it's
not as good well see many the second
time that second time that second time
was that second time was was bad car cuz
I died I didn't have the Divinity on it
that's fine
honestly I switched Rock come Lord at it
I like got to be sa I feel like the
sword was just I have to get too close
with them yeah sword is too risky I
agree that's why Cognito rocks that
savior [__] cuz he got to save you oh my
Lord acting like all four of you was on
right you still he got to save acting
like all four of you wasn't on that
right side and you still die shut
upul Nega
time
y looking like y need a
spear marked
enemies
we got to overload
middle overload G
mind teamw work make the Dream Work
whoever needs to be cleansed middle is
open all right they ain't dropping me
Rockets like crazy last
time
[__]
boss I was looking like up with they at
it it's fine I'm just shooting a rocket
over there every
time oh um WN W
yeah almost
done got him good [__] Taz if that was I
need
a Taz go on the other side yeah go on
the other side cuz we can't stack
divinities like
that
ghost
car
oh oh you playing around in the
middle another another one another
one okay we got another wag
coming
where's he at he's dead The Middle on
the right
side where did he go I don't know he
disappeared oh he coming he disappeared
M disappeared too yeah he's coming back
he's back over here over here on the
right right over here over
here
okay I'm about to die just an
Unstoppable get him in here get him in
here be careful getting
heavy y don't got pillars on right and
left it's only middle right
now
y now your pill are coming
up
yeah go damn they oh my God they a lot
they hit hit they hit left hard that
time mhm
uh uh wyvern on
left all
right wyvern's all
positions
God damn
reload down in the middle I'm down
anybody need help he's down he's dead
I'm down left side's down oh my God I
need help I need help I need help yeah
they left side needs help left side
needs help they sacrific on the conflux
they sacrific on the
conflux good
[__] I felt like that was just me and
you Cog what happened our support like
more on the right one more on the
right Middle's down
oh
God I'm trying to stay away from him I
got you at
it nice Forte one in the middle you got
it one in the middle left side it's
still
up there's
it all right I got it left side
down yeah but they captur middle they
captur middle
wver made
it we made
it use your supers if you have
to I think it's done it's
over no just got to kill the ads now no
I think I think it I think one goes in
the middle remember one like goes
strictly in the middle clear Middle's
clear got to clear all the died we're
all died we got to clear the before it's
time do it s overload overload on the
right over on the
right overload everywhere overload
everywhere nice good bubble
SC y got it guys got it let's
go oh my God who was hold up up for the
win at is scream for the win Confluence
Vision a ver too I got fou verdict y yo
s sin tell me how all the [__] talking
we did we the on at
the yo yo s
s hold up hold up hold up S you know
what was funny you know what was funny
Sid I had to like switch back and forth
with the the Divinity on the last two
overloads no I
didn't you
left Maybe
I didn't see you Forte my story you
weren't there yeah I only saw I only
saw attic screen I I died like right
after I dropped that bubble and then I
thought yeah I would have died I would
have died about that well I would have
died about that D we would have all been
dead if it wasn't for y held overload
over had cuz I kept I kept I kept
switching back and forth from them that
was good man that's going on YouTube
that's going on YouTube that that was
that was a crazy over they was about to
take the whole spot I'm sitting there
like I shot one I shot one and since
like oh [__] there's multiple and I was
like oh my God I'm just rotating back
and forth oh there it is all right so
this is the this is the oracles we need
the L shots Gage
on S no we're not strapping it to the
roof y remember where the oracles are
right pretty much they should be in the
same exact
spots I got to get this what you call it
should be good
though um uh what you call it you know
we used to make one person going back up
top why no right to call out all the
oracles why
virin remember they they they patched
that after this
yeah I'm let to
Scout I got to see if we could get up
there I'm sorry I got to go over there
you got to see I got to see if you can
go you got to test the
limits they let us up oh no there's a
turn back they put a turn back yeah they
put a turn back up there slowmo man
slowmo said I'm here to remind you guys
you're wasting your time that said this
is the that said this he can hear you he
can hear you
hear remind that division still has no
[Laughter]
content slow-mo you know what's funny
the fact hold up hold up hold up hold up
no slowmo they you know what's funny
like hold up hold up hold up let me let
me talk my talk slowmo the thing that's
funny is you're saying that it's sad
that this is the best trade and it's the
first trade name anything they can bring
back from the original destiny that be
as lit as this and get and get people as
excited as this
we being messy as H slowmo the the the
vision is so dry slow-mo people are okay
with anything at this point you get any
kind of update laugh he laughing he
laughing in
the throw his sland classic slander
Destiny he was waiting for us for me to
read that that's what happened y he
waiting for that is there another phase
between this and Oracle yes no no it's
or this is Oracle and D it's Temple
oh okay all right yeah I'm switching to
sniper I'm actually going to try Dead
Man's
tail that's what I'm should we use we
use the uh hidden uh like spot hey we
still have like uh one single ad sitting
over here yeah why is that one ad
here there's a couple of ads there's
like three there's three
ad why they resist to the I'm helping to
toen set
like why wasn't there a secret chest
over here in the hole Yeah Yeah it's
right here the
[Music]
left it used to be here it's right here
when you jump in it's still there once
you beat it you can go we got to beat it
first we got to shoot all the oracles
and stay alive on where is it
normally I thought it used to be like
right right here a hole wall on the
right side oh they put the turn back s
when you try to
climb this vision of Confluence it feels
like there's a like there's has where is
it where you guys see
it I'm shooting at
it oh it's
not all right you sure it's still there
m I don't know I look at slowmo slowmo
said the ledge remember I was talking
about the
ledge slowmo said they could bring back
survival when it would be lit you got
one thing man they could bring back
almost any raid besides croa really they
can bring U he does got us on this one
he said he said how many he said how
many years has it been since Bungie made
a new PvP
map he listen to last word yesterday
don't pay him
no complain so so so is that what
happened slow-mo you went on there and
used C's bar against him like yeah I
hate I hate that I said he takes notes
he takes notes yeah he he takes those
SL all right let's
go stay in the back right got wait for
the call it
left I to turn the volume up turn that
volume right now wait for the beat to
drop one on the right right side right
side right
side I got it marked my Oracle oh snap I
got to go oh I'm the I'm
I'm uh the thing disappeared it
disappeared yeah I cannot be
cleed who
died I did got sniped by the two snip
how he get to come back I can't
remember in the way yeah this is crazy I
feel
like
how do you get that stuff to come
back oh I hear one me I
it I'm clean I'm clean oh man I'm marked
again I don't I'm dead you don't got to
go in S I know but the thing's not there
it was day came back up you had to wait
I didn't I must I must have missed it
yeah know what it is the first time they
cleansed and then it went away and then
had to wait
again all right I'll go to the right
side where I was I guess I'll go we'll
go to the I kind of didn't go to the
same I think we need two people in the
back yeah two in the back I'll go in the
back two in the back front and like two
one in the middle each side yeah I'll
stay it back oh do you mean front by
like where I was like by the side of the
boss like where Forte what's back and
what's front back is start is back spawn
back back back is spawn front is towards
I'll always I'll go front I'm going
front with you there's Minot chars that
spawn back here so yeah are you guys
ready got to take him out immed back
then so be is back okay
yes all
right watch the snipers to come up from
the side yeah looking out for them oh
[__] I thought they the real
[__] I got
mine oh I'm marked I got to go left I'm
marked I got oh I forgot spawns I forgot
the boss spawns
here MH just white there's so many
people dead yeah how we used to get to
it fast enough we it's not that we got
to a fast we weren't dead like we're
just so they they're our level like we
we're used to doing this being so
overpowered over power
yeah did glad finish it yet he said did
glad finish it probably not challenge
mode is is ridiculous right now they're
on the boss still they're AP
yeah what's funny is we're not like I
like obviously we're not going to do
world first or anything like that but
we're not like mad far behind them
either doing we're too we got
the the Goblins that erase us and then
yeah I'm going to try to see this oh
they they won't let me stay in hit oh
man turn back that's foul budy that's
foul I think I might try a sniper for
this yeah this feel like a sniper the
situation one right there and I remember
one by the
[Music]
steps Mark for time I'm marked we got to
Jumping together everybody that's one
two three jump oh whoa w
he did the negation he already did the
negation he already did it yes means we
missed the Oracle we missed the Oracle
yeah I shot M everybody saw where the
Oracle spawn cuz I I saw attic kill his
attic kill
his yeah that's what it is we're missing
an
oracle I feel
like I feel like that I feel like that's
a right issue before we shoot yeah
everybody we should show body where the
yeah show everybody where the spots are
okay yeah I feel like that's a right
[Laughter]
issue why do you feel that's a right
issue cuz I saw I saw left go down one
spawns here so there's one let let me
let me go and just in case I got a right
here flashlight mhm get
flashlight one more ra is at this is the
one that I've been covering and that one
where's your third one where's your
third one third one I think is back here
isn't it or no it's back here it spawns
right here I think all right behind what
about what about left side left side one
spawns here wait hold on where you at
that's the one I think adct be killing
oh no I was that one and then he SP ad
killed the one that was here yeah I saw
that and then where's the third one and
then the third one's on the steps in
between the steps is hidden right here
that's the one that yeah this is the one
this is the one that screws
yeah this the one I was missing R said
looks like I is struggling with the
Vault of Glass
yikes oh stop it you stay there and you
can cover the one at the bottom of the
steps and the one in this corner guys
ready and I'll stay back here and I'll
try to cover this one in the corner as
well as the one back here starting it in
five somebody else
four three two yep
one s i if uh if someone can try to kill
both one person kill both so only one
person gets one I'm going for both I'm
going for whatever I didn't see any on
this
side I think they're on the middle and
right I didn't see any over
here I got
mine and there's one more up top there
one
more I got it got I got it I got sniped
I got sniped that's that other one Forte
can you see that one from where you are
yeah I got it that's the only other one
I might help
with oh there go I see it y I see I got
it it's immune it's immune though what's
up with that just showing you where to
come
okay behind
us all right I got that
one got
middle throw ice to help we REM Mar Mark
got to go to Middle yeah damn I got no
Clans hold oh I am still Clans oh I
still got the Clans at the end you got
it don't worry y i got this we all I
think I think we just missed by myself
worry about this all right I'm going to
go get something to
eat all right don't go to Apple bees and
be back in like don't go to four
hours you don't know my life like that
go to
public don't go to WWA leave it to send
something up that happen like a decade
ago didn't it happen in this
raid you don't know what contest mode is
please be
quiet until you explain what contest
mode is you non-rated
fraud you do not get to comment on
anything sir you sit back and watch
us you sit
back R why don't why don't you leave us
why don't you leave us alone and go make
an Xbox video man just leave us alone
and go do your own messy we can't have
that there don't you have it's like it's
like the game Simon they showing you
where they're coming up at yeah yeah
yeah don't don't you don't you have a
prediction video to make
R yeah he'll be messy all right so Forte
that one in the back the only reason I
just if you can see it sometimes uh I
just because I have this Minotaur that
just likes to come and stop I'm up here
with you oh
okay but I have a sword now so help that
this is the show right there on the
stairs where is the other over
here here it is okay I'll get it it is
right
there on the stairs get down good who
missed got the one over here who Miss no
you stole it I'm going to
die we have
to someone's missing their thing
someone's missing someone missing their
yeah I got
mine I got mine I got mine I got mine
all
right I got uh top what is that top
right got should we shout him out should
I shout it
out somebody was over with me on the
step when I was
like that should be attic attic should
be moving there three or four must be
four
six there's six in
total I got to
go no I'm covering two everybody should
be covering like two different places
just to
help L3 and L2 I'm Cognito on L1 and
and you can get there's one right
here okay and I'm covering R3 and I
think they changed it though I think you
can't get hit with the blast that he's
letting out the ritual of negation you
have to be behind the wall don't get hit
by his ritual of negation okay why cuz
his that bubble he's releasing I think
it's it's marking them R mess he said
watch you guys get ripped apart super
fast is more enjoyable than making a
video
[Laughter]
listen to the beat he he mess that's all
he be a messy
messy this is just
showing yep it's just showing just a
showcase and now the real one this will
be the real
one me I mared
mybody marked
too anybody CL guard out
was so who all right once again let's
see once again who missing adct was you
behind the wall when you when he did the
when he bubbled out no I went and
cleansed the hell they want us all to
step in at the exact same
time is it the mechanic when they get
seen I mean um if the if one of the
oracles is not killed is that's when
initiating the foration so that means
we're yeah we still missing s like we're
missing one miss round just listen
listen I Ked
L3 it show three of them down yeah I
think we're getting that right we're
Ming up a different mechanic
somewhere cuz you you hear how many he
makes right he only makes three first
like there's six at in the end but he
only has three that
time so maybe they just added a cleanse
so you have you think it's a mandatory
cleanse it's probably a
mandatory look that sucks is we all got
to go at the same time and if you miss
it yeah there's only
three yeah there's only
three there's only
three all right
Templar
where Mar
Markle all right dead immediately like
why is everybody dead immediately after
well cuz I'm not I didn't make it there
okay no it's not there so there only
three we all get marked you said what
pic I when I went to get in it wasn't
there yeah it's got to be we got to get
cleansed at the same time
right yeah we got to time it I guess
it's not making sense the oracles stop
the the getting marked the oracles
breaking the oracles is not stopping us
from getting marked there's something
wrong I I I
agree AG something else I mean there was
only one Oracle kill
so
mean or it's stand in the middle
oh we I don't think we've actually
killed all the oracles that's what it
feels like it feels you got to hit them
with heavy get them out of there don't
so maybe you're not killing them fast
like we're not hitting them kill them
you got to hit them hard all that's
probably what it is okay that's probably
what it is to they disappear when they
yeah they probably and then they
disappear I'm I'm shooting them with
like two snipers kills them okay I shot
like shot
shot all right I'll get this one over
here you can see that one the back
I got I can't see back got middle R1
back left the back right over there
right over there mine's
G cleans is gone though yeah I'm not
even seeing any I don't
understand that doesn't make sense at
all maybe we have to kill maybe we have
to kill the oracles at the same time he
wait a minute wait wait
you probably got to kill them in order
that they spawn in no that is it that is
it that is it I remember that that is it
we have to kill the order they spawn in
it's the order yeah look at Rand you
talking snap like ran first off we ain't
played this raid in like a decade what
it feels like okay second off like it's
easy to sit in the chat and talk [__]
you in the club
ATT pay attention to when your Oracle
spawns and you kill it in that order
yep just go one two three we'll count up
and you count the one you you say 1 2 3
4 5 6 R1 R2 R3 L1 R2 no we can't do that
we have to go in the order they spawn in
so you going have to go 1 2 3 4 5
six see one just
Cog I got two I didn't see
three I have
six all right Cog first one one down
killing two now there's someone messed
up will messed up I'm yeah
you I just saw it spawn I thought that
was no you you have to kill in the order
they spawn you got to wait for
everybody's order
yeah oh look look look at ran I even
know I'm sure ran I'm
sure I'm have to get you up out of here
man
[Laughter]
so are we doing top uh back I have a
question for
to no what you do I didn't know who had
what what number it's it's not you have
a number you count the number that they
pop in the order and you say I got one
someone else says I got two like you
hear the the order that they spawn it so
there's no reason people don't know that
oh oh I see right at the beginning I got
you so pretty much like like C C was
right near one so he had one I'm I'm the
problem is I'm kind of looking at two
over here on the right so I don't know
who's taking well you just the only time
on the beacon on the first beacons
is right right guys um I can tell that I
don't knowbody nobody's going to know
because they're not looking nobody's
looking over here uh Forte or t the
middle three right there right in front
of you it's three go back turn around
the other one the other one on the ledge
on the ledge over here that's three
three what about the one back one
down who's up one two where's two
where's two where's two now three will
three you're on will all right where's
three three's down recognizes that
refrain there we go oh there's only
three of six only yeah I was expecting
you was expecting six I know I know I
it
I got two I got three I got
three I got two
three I got killed I got killed I got
two some is anybody else looking oh
there's three's up three's up there one
gone there one gone y you're one you're
one no I I was two I wasn't one you did
I just don't know who else is looking
hold on hold on hold on hold on hold on
we got to change this up we got to
change this up hold on I feel like I'm
kind of off by myself no I'm over there
next to you what are you talking about
we you're not over there next to me
you're but I got a sniper rfle and I'm
looking at R1 and R2 okay so can you get
okay all right so you're looking at R1
and have to worry about those I got R1
and R2 all right so then I should just
worry about R3 adct Incognito y'all
going to worry about the oracles I'll
handle ads on the left side sir Taz you
handle all the all the ads and then let
them worry about the um or and the
middle or cuz I'm standing right next to
the middle
orle so I got middle Oracle all the time
in and I got you got that left yeah yeah
so you can worry just about the oracles
and you don't have to worry about ads
I'll just run around killing everything
okay so we got I got left Taz got middle
hold what was one got two one is well
well one is the first one
on Three is Middle all right so there
ain't no left for me so I could add
clear the one is is right over here yes
that's one kill that one we know one's
dead two's
dead fre there we go or or refrain from
destroying
us I
got Who's down you got
4 three is left yeah I got it I got
three tell me when y I'm three I'm four
I'm four I'm four Middle's two nobody
head I'm
down oh my God might rotate the middle
somebody got to get three after the
first two down I'm
down disappearing it doesn't matter half
the team's dead what you mean
disappearing jump off
then this is what we're going to have to
do we're going to have to have I your
SAR we're going to have to have two on
each side do ad clear and one on each
side do the oracles man because the the
ads is the problem like the snipers are
killing us the ads yeah like one one
person on each side is just going to
have to keep up I'll do ad clear I'll do
ad clear and Forte you focus the oracles
okay left cuz I'm just I have a lot of
AD clear right now mhm and I have sniper
so I can do the who's in the back on
left
side uh
me help me with the snipers here and
there I'm doing add clear
but so you don't want focus on left or
just want me to do add clear with
snipers cuz I'm going to run back and
forth and I can help as well see if if
if if you have one person on on the side
always worry about the snipers one
person on the side worry about the FOC
on the left yeah to get them you got the
you got that's fine we'll hand that's
fine that's fine that's a good
idea cuz the snipers is messing me up
too I got one I got three and two over
here one and two I got one I got one
three
I got one and two yeah one and
two tell me when both of them are dead
one's dead Mark for n time I didn't do
it right yeah you hit you hit the wrong
did out of
order it's going to take a couple
seconds for us to get used to that I'm
switching to a
sniper
mm that might be a good idea Dam I
didn't bring no sniper with me I'm
bringing Cloud
strike is working
now is working fine for me I'm switching
to a sniper and the sleeping simulate
because I could just shoot them with
those uh opening
shots yes sir oh I got too much stuff on
me
okay
Titan
all right so what we're going to do is
uh I'm going to use a sleeping simulator
on this side and I'm just going to stay
up here on this top and shoot
that I can see I can see this one over
here uh that's on the staircase I can
see the staircase that cognos on and I
can see the one under here so what I
would do is I'll just I'll shoot them
with the sleeping because I got I got 13
bullets I got the the catalyst
so just keep the snipers
off I'll be looking for
him when going to start it know I think
somebody leave or
something there everybody I put a shield
up for you you could have put it a
little bit better it's like straight off
the map okay middle
two where's the Third One S I don't see
the third
one thir one's by me I me one no the
first one's by you all okay okay what it
was first
the
little
to middle
one L middle I got
three two I don't know where one
is
get the first
one tell me when it's done one I think
it was left two oh my
God yeah willham you killed one you
weren't supposed to kill
one might like yeah it's a
white s the only one I can't really see
is the one that's that's uh right by
where the Templar
is you handle that one that's the only
one I really want you to to worry about
cuz I can't I can see all of them on the
right side I just can't see that
one low key about to put on
a we'll put
that go get us could we jump out there
no I want to try
that so someone started
it y
just three is the one in the
back the left side it's it's on all on
his side besides the one on the
back yeah someone messed up Forte it was
you I know it was me I didn't know I was
trying to change stuff but I had me too
yeah I was changing St too I love that
it rats people
out
what I knew I did it I was just shooting
one just so we could start over
MH you only have to do this six times
too that's the uh I mean you have to do
it what when it has six that's the last
one mhm we got we got up to four like we
just do this a couple times we'll get
through
it
we just got to get this down like I I
think we can easily do
it co do me a favor what's up see this
one here tell me when it pops up on the
stairs that you normally are at where
you at the one that pops up on the
stairs I think you can see it from here
from this spot right here you can see
all three oh okay you just put a shield
up on your left and you'll be good okay
okay it's just hard to see that stairs
but I can go grab it all right you guys
ready yeah I'm ready what you good yeah
I'm good
okay check
it which number one I got one I got
one all right this is
[Music]
third
one's down no that it wasn't one one was
in the
B where will
was where was Will at where's
will just
White
Rand stop trolling he's done yeah
trolling two flags double
ammo
oh
man think right here right here I'm
good I can see all three from right
here CU see four of them actually and
the center just it's the sequence we got
to tight up all right one two three
one's the one in the middle two's the
one over here one is here one is by me
and three somewhere over there with
Forte I got three I got three over
here one I'm taking it down it's
down got to use that Xeno it was I was
still going to shoot it doesn't matter
as long as we get it in the right
sequence you got plenty of
time oh my God Eyes Of Tomorrow is
amazing two three two's over there where
midd two over here
with one stairs left
side and three is in the back three
Middle's in the back three I got got
one that one and two
down
down whoa Sniper got me I got you I got
you I got you sniper
[__]
yeah I got
one last one's Sinister where he is
one's where I
am I got four I got one
okay got it one me and Forte are both
down what you going to
do days it's a rra okay now it's five
too
not going front
y'all Isa tomorrow is super lit for the
snipers that's uh you and Sir Taz are
dealing with snipers is it tomorrow
which one is that that's
theck oh my God like you just line them
up soon as they see
line them up marck him Rockets just go
to one hit get him out of
here the volume yeah we got to hear them
sounds all right she starting it
everyone ready
MH
bomb's
clear I I got one two's on the stairs
three I got
three one's down got two two's down
three
down
I got one oh I'm down two is back here
attic three is by me and three three is
left oh my God who's got four four steps
I'm
down got it call him out when youill him
one I got
two I got three got
three where's four we got it we got it
we got it we got them all okay oh I'm
dead damn these things hit
hard the little guys got me listen
listen one I got three I got two I got
two no I got one I got
one all right
got one we're out of order already right
no no one two three oh Sinister
Mark I'm dead I'm
dead
I'm here I'm I got I got killed oh okay
I I didn't know he were uh here when we
started
snipers yeah it's bad right
now no rest for
you I'm dead his left
side he's
dead that's five too man we just do it
two more times two more times yeah cuz
you have to do it six and then you have
to do one more six and then it's
over
well on the six one you can just shoot
all everybody can just shoot once we're
good yeah what you switching to
Tar nothing shooting Arc at me at
all bu one I can just stand there with
the bubble on
point that's a good point I might might
I might get down with you on
that they start sniping I still got I
can take you got the sh yeah you can
take you can also sword the oracles that
seems to be working pretty good if you
need like a fast kill like when the
Oracle pH starts coming up I've just
been going full sword all right I'm
shooting it
ready oh no no I'm not ready no he's
switching
out I we almost had it that time we was
on
five
you know what it
is I feel like this is how we should do
it the two are on each side and the
people that are doing the oracles
they're both in the middle cuz they can
see the whole map from the
middle
[Music]
one so Forte do you want to do that do
you want to just sit in the back of
snipers
[Music]
water yeah that's what we need to do we
two people need to be back with snipers
and the rest are just doing ad
clear what about the back ones you'll
have to worry about that one cuz there's
only uh there's only oh two in the back
and you can handle both of
those I'm
ready under the butt but we we can see
we could see them though like we just we
got to know not to shoot them that's
all hey guys I think I found
something some hiding
spots ready I'm ready whenever you guys
ready
huh you can stand right here you're fine
look at this before you
start hey oh wow I see
you you can chill up here last space up
here oh focus focus get
back all right one is
me one is front right I'm going to say
front
right two different came out I see two
and three
kill it will dead I got two and three
there we
go fail s we got the H Goblin in the
back I'm two I think I got one I got one
I got three I got three or I did four
Jesus man nobody told me this minur was
still up and just walked
oh I got four I got four one I got one
I'm
dead I got
two I have two Four's in the back
will well I don't know who order I don't
know who's killing anything anybody kill
him back anybody you got to shout it out
you got to shout it out I you got to say
when you do it that's the only thing we
got got the only we got we got guys we
got you got to know I feel that
shoot that thing I I think maybe we're
having trouble just people alive knowing
which one is which cuz no it's not that
people are dying that's the issue people
are dying we have to always regroup
every time someone dies and then people
Miss what order they're in because
people are regrouping and
Reviving got it makes
sense
me just let us know as best we
can I'll pay for it since I died let me
see if I can find a better spot cuz I
got shot in the back also yeah cuz I
going say s there's there's a a a HG I
can't get to that's probably killing you
that's all the way back I K I killed him
I killed him y there's one that that's
always here where I'm shooting yeah I I
always shoot him I shoot him right here
okay all right I be seeing him alive I
see him alive and I think that's the one
that's killing
okay I got one I got two I got three
[Music]
okay one's down two
down Zen that thing out quick you see
what I mean about Zeno I'm not lying
yeah is he know the [__] and you can use
it on the
snipers
yeah I got one again I got two I have
three I have three I have two I got four
I got one and four I got one and
four I got
two one's down two's
down oh I got sniped three's down
down
go yeah that not it I have one repent
not it I have one and
three I got
three I got two I need help on the left
side I got three and
four I got two I got two
one's down two's down three's
down where is it where's
four it's in the middle oh it's too late
oh I should have said I would have had
it
bushes he was playing with that there
Forte we killed our [__] literally at
the same time I just killed my I'm
telling you that Zeno right
Zeno I'm about to grab Zeno yeah I'm
grabbing Zeno Zeno's just one shot yeah
oh you found the water
guns go take we're clearly getting
somewhere though we're definitely
getting somewhere yeah give me a second
I just got
a go take it to her and say let's play
water gun it's hot
outside it's 88° go wet yourselves you
guys are little
kids
bro you know one hit on the Oracle y all
right one second me I'm getting down
that
program I got to I don't want to do it
but
I I just infused the sleeper in the Xeno
page I ain't going back to the tower you
can always pull the sleeper back out
of it's not
happening he said go back to the to what
you mean I said I'm not not going back
to the tower that's what I thought you
don't have to go to the tower that I I I
that's why I did it cuz I didn't want to
go back to the
tower oh I saying you could just pull a
collection cuz the I have the sniper for
some of the are we
ready hold on hold on hold
on is hurry oh it's 1100 that's why I
thought it was just maxed out
regardless
will yes
sir know about the secret
spots I
do that's where I
went
just all right I'm ready there's a
there's a thing up there now there a
kill yeah kill bear there's not not
everywhere
though that's where I was what about
behind this rock can you shoot it from
behind this rock yeah right here yeah
you can stay back the ads ain't your
problem the ads aren't your problem you
get snipers though ads do come over okay
yeah the
snipers yeah
yeah oh I might try it
again I got three thre is a
I got one and two I got one and two
okay one down two
down three I need help with beginning
and the middle all
right I'll stay in the middle then I
help you out no one's taking out the
third
one I don't have anything to pick you up
at
it I'm down I got him I got him I got
too many ads yeah too many
ads yeah t just let me know where you
want want to
help
middle I got three I got
three
this just so you know left was ad your
left side was the first one who me mhm
no it was the third one not the first
one they all went through with the third
one it was there was three on the left
the first one was left the second one
was on right side but my point is is
they got all of them with the third the
fourth one was back left no the stairs
wasn't even a one on that on the first
one that
[Music]
happened
shoot
you can
see what I need assistance with ads up m
in the middle I got a lot more ads I'm
dealing with than everybody else by
myself yeah my bad I'll go in the middle
to help you out with the ads Chad that's
my bad it's all good I was so focused on
sniper help so that they don't get
killed iot you getting overrun over
there love
that yeah if the if the oracle's not in
the middle I I can I can take care of
right but it's when it's in the middle
that's when they go crazy okay yeah I
got
you I got one I got
two and three I got two and three oh you
can get
three one's down two's down down all
right
what minute I was trying and
me oh my God that Xeno Fage is
amazing I got
two I think I I got three I got
four I got two two is on steps I got
yeah four I got four in mid I got two
here one oh I got sniped will three fre
over there next to my body
for
negation took too long if you have
um turn them off turn them off turn them
offs are bu the oracles
really oh I didn't know
that say that
again oracles when you pop them okay
never mind sorry taking it off Ed the
war my Jo my uh my carbine me because my
carbine made
one all right my didn't know
that I haven't using
my get that off I use the charge of
light
[Music]
build all right it's off
all right you guys ready
yeah I
got
hurry I got one I got three I got
three
one one down Uh Oh wrong order wrong
order just
why you had
two no I I didn't shoot any of
them cuz the one I had was
three middle ad I think yours was
one mine later
I know I had
one well whoever shot first was yeah it
was Forte you didn't have
it he said Forte killed an oracle got
the only Oracle kill
so me and stare at it yeah pick what
it's you can blame all you want but the
truth is
there the truth they set you free I
guess I guess I was
wrongly silly silly Hunters what T world
that's what we
do one I have one I got two and three
two and
three save your got
one
I got one I got two I got three I got
four I got
one got
[Music]
it
somebody going shoot two I got
three I don't know I shot the middle cuz
nobody was shooting anything no because
no one shot two what side was two on let
me ask a question why would I shot two
why would you shoot three why would you
shoot middle and you know middle was
last cuz nobody else shot I shot two and
then I shot the middle middle was
middle
nobody
shot yeah I that though yeah I think I
could GL that back yeah see I I shot two
Forte shot uh one and he shot two in the
first round so uh someone didn't kill
the
second so I got to put glue in here and
then push it down and hold it there
until
lat yeah my son came going up to me yeah
I know that's why you ain't shoot your
orac
I waso somebody
else I shot two in the
back that that's not what the number
said my friend that's that's not what
the number said Forte for it said you
killed one Oracle drinking bottles in my
don't you don't you don't don't you love
how this man said he killed two oracles
and it said he only killed one that's
one one's down shoot someone shoot two I
don't have two all there's three three's
down
I got one again and I two one I got one
three one three and let see one two and
four I got one two four on this side I
got three let me know when two one two
one and
two
or's
down I try to help you with the snipers
bro yeah I appreciate it I got too many
ads I
can't I got
one I got two I got three and four I'm
sniped pick me up to your
left I got three over here okay I got
four I see one got one and six I got two
or one in what's
that one's down let me know when two's
down I down three's down Four's down
Four's down five's
down I got one I got
two three I'm dead up in that oh I died
Co H me I fell off the map I got
you that's
three I got three four or
five one's down
two two's
down
no
will man I I don't hear you
communicating at all what's going on
over there like yeah haven't heard will
I I keep I've been I keep saying I was I
was dead and but nobody but nobody's
really near me that's the thing like I'm
kind of like up to he's off in the
boonies like I
am H I went down Forte went down he got
revived and then I was
I was trying to get to him but then he
got revived but then I got killed
cuz it feels like Forte doing everything
over there fam like I'm just being real
he has seven Oracle kills
like I just feel like Forte's putting
himself in more Harm's Way and it's
getting him
killed I mean I'm right
here I
mean look look a lot look you're right
there but the numbers ain't saying you
there
fam and I'm covering this orle
hasn't come up in a
while but anyway the I got one and two I
got
three I got three three's left side yep
yeah I got it one's down two's down
two's down three's
down
I got two I have three and four two and
four I got two and
four man the snipers are e me
alive oh I'm going to die I got down oh
I'm going to
die down
Four's
down oh my God I got sniped by the
sniper I got two two I got two and four
K I thought I got two hold up one one I
got one I got three I got three never
mind I got one I I got five I got five I
got two oh I got SN oh my god dude I'm
down will one the bottom of
stairs
okay one two three
four that's four four right there oh
come on
man I'm going to get for no we're dead
we're dead we're dead I don't have
anything to pick for up someone said
they got four so I
shot I did get
four I mean Forte said I had
four so what happened at that last one
so I shot five before four because
someone said they had
four got it I wait till I see the kill
feed though I don't I I look the kill
feed but it was already delayed I I
didn't think we had much time that's why
I just shot them what is that thing that
icicle that's an interesting oh that's
that new thing I don't know that's
something car keeps dropping I keep
grabbing and throwing them [__]
[Music]
so I don't want to be Batman anymore
okay take it off who's still alive why
you wasted my
times
still
he said he's soloing the last part he's
soloing it was solo man that way we
could be
done let me take a leak while you do
that be right
back like how you going to say you
wasting my
time was time like you really wasting
his time
right I mean unless he's literally going
to solo it he should probably
Justman
we all know this is to be a joke in this
16 hours 18 hours no I could still been
you know running around killing right
now standing here looking
at look I couldn't I couldn't have
foresee car need to take a piss okay
yeah I could still been running
around
yeah
see
here by the way if you hit a Oracle with
a sword it instant kills
him
just actually give me about 10 minutes
I'm going go smoke give me about 10 days
I'll be right
back
all right I'm
back you left and he you came back and
he left who
left
had to put the whack headsets on yeah me
too I was like I
need
mhm your
um your weapon drop did it drop with
like a Oracle like an enhanced Oracle
you know shooter thing M dropped was
moment disruption
break oh yours has a Oracle
B no I was wondering like back in the
day they used to destroy oracles
faster you could probably get that as a
mod a drop mod
now inside of
your where
where did my new mods go looking in the
mod section I don't see mods
he B is at the oracles he's like where
yeah yeah we
struggling at the Oracle part m is this
where he is too yeah he's there too I
was like the contest mode is the issue
it's like a lot of things are hitting
harder we got the plan we got
straighten
yeah I want to use
my but Taz is right and kid like damn
it
e
everybody's back
or somebody said 10 minutes oh
okay oh
okay T like I got stret I get on my
nerve I got
smoke everyone speak up does people need
to around like are we good with where we
are whatever you want to do man I mean I
I feel like I'm good helping out with
the um yeah clearing with him in the
middle and then snipers you don't work I
see I see the you got okay so you got
like 150 kills or something like
that yeah I'm trying to help out
wherever is at whatever yall overwhelmed
yeah what's up what's up stre uh I think
I have an idea this really easy okay so
uh follow me if you will for a second uh
oh I I have looked I have not looked at
the left side I've only looked at the
right but I can imagine something like
this will work so come here so for the
backside this back right uh spot this
area right here this is what I suggest
I'm going to suggest we put two maybe
three guys here to Simply either look at
the bottom of this stairs or really just
that right Cor Corner mhm because this
spot mhm right here can be covered by
the guy that is up
here all right looking down and he can
be fine and the one in the middle or one
on the right can be covered by the guy
that's sitting right here
M or right where is another spot let's
see maybe even like right there
yeah you
got yeah I found a secret spot oh he's
in the walls wall yeah he's already in
the walls he's already doing scream
stuff
well if there's a few spots where like
people could like sit without having to
worry about getting killed we're we're
not doing that oh in that spot too right
there you can actually come out if
there's just a few spots where people
could sit without you can double load
you in this game without glitching like
be real like you do anything in this
game without glitching but it's a puzzle
I figured it out it's not a puzzle it's
not a
puzzle I don't know ad you should be up
here you can shoot two a
puzzle a spot to get a good but he wants
to be active with the um you could be in
and out well then you could like not
worry about ads and everybody could just
cover like or we could just play Destiny
how about that like we could just
play hey I'm in the game that's
plan the game allow if you're not
trying you Ain ain't competing buddy
shout out to the LZ y in the chat he
said stit ask any hunter R void what's
up man we do it your way Za what's up
brother you mean you mean do it the
game there's just so many good spots
here look where Forte is he's up there
he found it look if you feel you need
that you can go do that man if you feel
like you need that then go do
that you know who I am of course I feel
like I oh I found one for me found I
found one for me let's go let me see
what you see I I don't even know where
they are over there Taz is back I'm
starting Taz is back I'm starting no no
no no no show him I got now you found a
great spot you found a lit
spot oh you know this is actually a
really good this is actually a really
good spot right here for me to kill
everything on I can
[__] man you see you see this spot
right
[Music]
here I'm quite I'm quite I I think
there's a reason people keep dying cuz
they do only do glitches they don't play
Destiny oh yeah there we go this is a
good spot these spots are here for a
reason okay
okay we are not proba chill with me up
here and you take no damage and you can
shoot that back one and you can put one
right here I fell off laughing look look
look will will look up here you can
shoot your [__] and not get hit by
nothing I know oh perfect there we go
that's where I'm going do y had me
laugh well we we have we have as many as
we can okay I'm I'm starting you
cheaters I'm starting start yet that's
right you can't you can't start it what
he's not back yet no listen he's been
back all let's go one I got
two
I got
three
one y calling it yeah I already said one
two two uh sinister sinister that you
were
too look at that man we were doing good
we we were doing good people getting
these little people getting these little
cheese spots that we just go
downhill shout out to damn Omar he out
here laughing at us why are we
resurrecting
people what are you doing
will
alive
name oh my God bu knows about their
bunie knows they put these onp bu they
had enough time with this
game
eics I'm questioning no I'm questioning
a lot of [__] right now man I'm
questioning a lot of [__] here we go get
in the
mark all right so we need fall out then
you got to go back to your spot go back
to my spot that's how we do it
guys if I'm a Hunter that's the cheese
let's just go yo yo I'm just I'm just
I'm just putting out there we have an
lfg to replace will I'm just putting
that out there no we
that's will he's a specialist
specialist he's he's our R specialist
something special something he's
definitely special he's definitely
special that's right like ain't no one
going to disagree with you on that
particular set of skills yeah you know
you have to appreciate that in the
rain Dam said we got to use the glitches
to our advantage
the get get your cheating asses out of
my
chat but I don't mind look here here's
here's the real Realo I don't mind the
glitches when when like you done
something a thousand times and you just
want to get through it no these are
exploits these are exploits no these
These are exploits you exploit Guardians
that's what you are you're exploit
Guardian
Focus Lis
Focus I got one I got
three I got
two in the
middle I'll get two Forte you got it
already Okay I'll get
it and Forte messed up immediately I did
not shoot it I didn't I didn't even get
no no Forte killed it it said it it
snitched on him no I did I did shoot it
I did
twice oh my God I hate you guys
[Laughter]
[Music]
like said use the glitches to your they
laughing with us with this they like you
got a glitch you got to you got a glitch
you gotta use it people wonder why they
can't stay alive because they keep using
glitches I'm hey the guy using the
glitch is alive
you doing your you you realize that you
realize you you know how much time you
keep wasting just sitting there running
around when half the team's dead and
we're trying to Wi we're going to Save
the Day ad we're going to save the day
we're going to save the day okay still
alive it is defense he is still alive
wait a minute is that [__] is that
[__] uh is that is is that [__]
[__] keeping you that alive oh hell you
a get that c bro I don't have damn you
you didn't see the clip I put up on
Twitter in The Crucible at that's
hilarious in the thep yesterday
[__] running around like that
oh bro it it's straight straight de like
about fall off the back let's go let's
get these numbers together we got it's
in the back it's in the back it's in the
back all right there we go next I'm
going to have to start saying Cognito
needs to exploit next stop joking yeah
I'm going need to exploit St fall the
maple
I don't know what the hell I'm drunk I
got one I got two I got
three
one one's down two
I wish snipers had anti
bear I got
one I got three I got four I'm dead how'
you die up there how' you die up there I
got killed by
the I got you I got two I got
two one's down two's down three
down
damn
it I got
two oh my God these
snipers yeah give me give me give
me I got two I don't have a token for
you I have S you're going to have to
take three and four you're going to have
to take four and five s someone's got to
come get me okay somebody got to get out
I'm dead again what's the number only
thing and real when you die in that spot
it messes up the flow because then I
gotta go the way get you and I can't
protect adct got find a better spot how
about you don't die adct now has to deal
with more snipers and then if he goes
down I'm out of position yeah hey hey
hey hey Will I hey hey Will Will how
about you don't
die fair enough yeah Liz um I think
scream is running breaching clear mod
yeah it's a crazy mod bro
I don't know are you running that will I
don't know what you're running
mhm I was I'm running a sniper now mhm
um feel like we're we're we're we're
digressing man he was doing good now
feel like going back down
manr this bannner for the victory we got
this it's over this it focus
focus don't let me catch you in a hole
spot he didn't get to the spot oh man oh
my go well go go
go I got
three I got one and two one and
two
one two
three one I got
two I got two I got I'll get this one
back I got two two and three I I got no
no I have two I have two I got three and
four I got three and
four got that one that
one
oh got one I got two I got three snip I
got you I got you 14 no T Focus I got
him
I got
two I got five I know I got
five one's
down three's down [__] I'm down yeah I
can't pick them up ad going to have to
get
Ted
a [__] I
died I got
six I got
you the best I got
three I got
four four and five hitting
me down
one
two where's two where's two two
three it's cleans cleanse cleanse just
cleanse I'm not going to make
it I think we're good though are we good
no we need one more six we need one more
got six we need one more
ah and
scream
I got
two too many people down yeah better
much better though cim how's that spot
for you like you got a dou spot or um
sort
of we got to figure out a spot for you
friend I'm more a safer spot sa this one
spot is very very
um it's is is it accessible if if it
goes left if it it go down I mean yeah
it's pretty accessible yo don't we only
got to stay alive
now you got to stay alive you got to
stay
alive all right
good I mean oh no there's another one no
there's another round never
mind you try to smash me
off
two if I just stay alive when it get
marked no you get marked but is there a
cleanse left that's the
issue I don't know he's mared we don't
know if we have a a last cleanse oh what
I died from the drop from the fall the
that's foul that's F Well that
definitely works though hey uh c m hold
up what's
up
privacy
privacy want to kick Sinister it's
terrible it was about about look Co look
we going to be here all night if we
don't get rid of sinister now we ain't
going to get the raid
[Laughter]
done he's not averaging his
numbers I'm here yeah I'm here I got it
already I got one and two and three
Jesus Christ
one two three will yep what about from
right here I saw it from right here like
if spot yeah you can get it from
there oh I fell one is right here I got
two I'll get it for I'll get this one
the
first okay
okay
one one's dead two died from
snipers man I hate when they do
that a it's a it's a r i missed it I
missed it
yeah m white stop me boss is there any
others you we can cover from up there
there's got to be at Le one the only the
only thing scream is when you're in that
spot I feel like add control for Forte
becomes
harder yeah and that that's the problem
you saying so it's like even though I
like this he doesn't have to go back
there at all he just needs to cover that
right side from the back cuz will has
that that back
one I just need to cover the snipers and
stff yeah I feel the ACT control the
snipers on that side cuz what's
happening is I'm I'm having to do
oracles and sniping control on the left
because I'm doing my circle run I'll
I'll hit Taz see what's going on with
him and boom I'm checking on adct see
what's going on by the time I get over
there that side is crazy a with the
snipers and stuff cuz that that he can't
focus on what he need to
do nothing on this side one and
three
one yeah one and three I got one and
no one get two two is down
three I tried to keep that sniper off of
you say one two I see
two
is there four
now yeah okay I have four when somebody
goes was the other one yeah I I took two
I took two okay got it no there was
nobody who got three out of water yeah I
hear too far I didn't hear Too
Far
wor we got to just keep it in order yeah
I didn't hear nobody call out after two
nobody said I got three I got
or
yeah I would
agree it looks like that biomutant game
is going to sell more just because of
all this bull [__] happening oh the $2
99 wait what's going on with that what's
up with
that off
the was it a mess
up yeah they changed that [__] like 1:00
in the morning they made it oh so people
were coping it for two die yeah
wow two I got
three one down two where's two one two's
down three's down there you go now the
call outs are good everybody said
something
one I got two I I think I have
three are you sure that's two I feel I
got three and four I got three and four
three and four I got two one down two
down
I got one got one and two I got one and
two oh these
snipers got five I
think three is on that one side
s I'm
dead taxon you get me what
one and two are down get that one right
there s that's three I shot three I'm
down he got him up he got him
up who got four four and now get five
Four's in the middle Four's in the
middle Four's in the
middle y got it n too
late we need
survivability yeah again I had to go
save screen yo put put your wells down
do whatever you stay alive yeah yeah
don't yeah don't be cheap with the
supers don't don't tuck the supers and
get behind use
them
everybody's
let's say why don't you try dropping
with hord for the ad control yeah the
problem is Liz with great the snipers
that's what the issue but it's the
snipers having um Xena phase with the
one hit sniper is more important like I
those snipers onol on contest mode it's
crazy trust me I want to use with ho
too I'mma drop bubbles in the back with
a yeah just keep feeding each other uh
middle just drop it in the middle and
then so they just run in and run out y
you guys ready yeah I didn't start
that we're
good I got one I got two I got
three
one down two
down three
down now it's strictly ads kill the ads
kill the
ads I tried to keep the snipers under
control I got three
yeah I got
uh I got two and three one no I got two
and four I got two and four
I got one I got two and four one down
two three
four man they they're sneaking up on
me I got
three in the back
yeah
I got one over I got two I got two I got
two
three one
dead two's dead
three
[__] man these snipers keep coming back
Qui yeah they keep spawning them I keep
killing so many they keep
spawning somebody got I got him one I
got one over
here I got one and
two you get that one over there
Forte yeah I got one I got two I got
three four and five I got four and
five one's down two's down three's down
four and five oh my
God I got four and five six six
whoever's doing six I got it we got
six I killed like oh I think I'm going
to die
[__] one is on
me somebody got him I got two I got
snipers snipers are messing me up
I'm trying to get every side
[Music]
of I got three and four over
here I got last one no yeah I definitely
have six I got
five one's down I believe this is two
three go three four there's three
four there's
four Templar
Templar that was that was six over here
here somebody killed it before they got
five I had six and somebody killed F
somebody that's fine though that was a
good run that was a good run that was a
good run that was a good like I got it
on the real though like the the snipers
are ridiculous look at what I'm doing
though look at my hob bro no no I'm not
I'm not I'm I'm not I'm not saying
you're not doing I'm just saying they're
ridiculous like like every every time I
literally killed one back to back like
the same one and they're spawning them
so fast like I'll kill him I'll go back
to respawn again cuz I know I know
you're doing a lot over there so I'm
trying to take as many out on the left
as I can and then you got to understand
there's two that comes up on Forte and
scream side that I gotta you're not
supposed to that's sir Taz side isn't it
true no but Taz got the middle cuz the
middle beat they be trying to overrun
it's crazy they throw mad ass middle lot
so I got to help him with the Adge I
gotta go make sure addict's not getting
sniped with the two joints and then the
right side I always check just to make
sure Forte and focus on the thing unless
y'all want to add another person that's
strictly hob golin kill with me cuz they
they're sporting we're fine we're fine
we're fine cuz I I'm taking out the
majority on the left you're just taking
the ones that I can't do somebody shot
the wrong Oracle that's
all no one's saying yeah no one's saying
no one's saying you're not doing what
you're supposed to no I know I know I
know that I'm just saying that I'm just
letting you know the frequency of the
Hob Goblin spawning is insane I'll kill
them turn back and they literally when
it's six they're they're spawning
between every all of them are spawning
every Oracle has two I got one has
two I got
one I got this one
for one
dead one one and I get one I got one I I
said it I got one no I didn't hear you
say one oh I did not hear you say last
one last one shoot it shoot it thank you
AR it don't argue just do
it good [__]
up I got one didn't he I got
three I got
four I got
two one down
two three
four one I got
one two and three I got two and three I
got
four I got two and
three one down two down three down four
down
three I got
four five three and
five
one I got
two two and I got I got glitch three
five three and five my well
sorry I went down for three and
five three and five where's
one one two two where's
two um yeah you got a rest for me oh
where are you where are
you I really messed up the right side on
that
one there's [__] snipers behind me
man I killed them and they came right
the [__] back they came right the [__]
back cuz I'm trying to take out them
quicker I'm trying to take them as quick
as I can but literally I killed the ones
in the back of a grenade and I turned
around and they came right back like cuz
as you can see I saw you cuz I I you I
was coming over to help and you was
taking care of them but they was fall me
back so then I went back over the other
side yeah it's crazy them hob Goins is
nuts I'm trying to snipe the one at the
back left so he don't [__] with sin
where is sniper where's the sniper damp
at's the chest piece chest piece chest
piece yeah you would have put on sniper
resistance sniper damage resistance CH
chest piece middle well the good thing
is it takes two shots to kill me so
usually they don't get me but what gets
me is when they shoot consecutively both
of them that's it's these two in the
back H like [__] Dave and dawn
whatever the [__] their names are it's
up on the back left man they they always
get
me yeah real so I'm trying to look at my
radar when they spawn Oh I thought we
were ready two no three I don't have
three I don't have three yeah I don't I
got three
one one
down two
down
one three three
four I got three four I got four no no I
have four
I mean four is right near me two
snipers
three four somebody off yeah see yeah it
was it I told you that that it the the
number got messed up I knew I was I had
four I had
four I had four I'm I'mma go back and
look at my stream I had I'm confident I
had
four confident I had four
it's in the past just do it no it's not
in the past I got a stream I'm looking
it up I'm like I'm making sure I was
right don't worry about it don't worry
about it who cares yeah you're you're
going off on a
tangent
it has
been I got to get those ones on the left
a lot
quicker I got to get those two on the
left a lot
quicker they spawn right after the other
ones I got one I have two will two two
and three okay you get three I'll get
two
okay
who who hit that like I did who
just you see but like that's no no no no
that was just that first
time but the thing is is that's messing
stuff up like let them do the their
stuff yeah let whenever you call it
out I didn't call anything I know I know
three I got
three I got one and four I got two I got
two
I I'll help you get the one one two got
three four there's
four behind you appreciate
it oh these snipers are up here I'm
about I'm coming I'm
coming I have two I got three I I I have
I guess I'm
four one two two I have
two I got four five I got one and
five
one
2 3
five oh my God man it's hard keeping up
with all these or stay alive stay alive
Focus
two I got
three I got
two two I have two and four five I'm I'm
I'm one and
six one three I got
killed too many ads on me six I got you
scream thanks
man I think we just got to survive
they're not doing it again
okay I got
four in the middle I think I'm yeah I'm
trying I'm trying I have six full has
six oh I'm dead to all Taz you got to
pick up attic yep I got two or we got I
got one and five I got six I think I got
two and four I got two
three two's down oh my three [__] down
[__] I'm
down six six six is down
nice I'm going to go get okay Al bubble
behind
us thank you oh I'm about to die from
the snipers
I think we got it we got
it yeah oh my God yo I completely
guessed that that last one I died and
when he got me up I was like it's guy
like literally I was like I'm
two getting the same drops I you know
what's funny I was like I was yo yo you
know what's crazy oh Surplus andzy hold
up hold up hold upus and
Firefly I I got I got found verdict you
know what's funny like I said I was was
like I think it's two and someone said
two was like I think it's three
like cuz I was I was taking the the far
left in the in the
staircase yeah bro what was this one how
do we do the one person runs
around so we could do damage
right feels do it feels do Mark
rememberer got unmark with yeah yeah
right no I'm saying yeah he said it's
spting randomly said I yeah it's a test
that's what R's about man those moments
right there you live for that it clutch
is there a lot of add clear for this I
can't
remember I believe I believe so we got
to have
ours DPS
item I'm actually going to stick with
Z is this a focus DPS like a yeah every
time man I don't I rarely sweat but my
hands were sweating that time like all
right I'm going sleep then can I go back
with war M cells that was my favorite
gun don't you have to do Oracles in this
take got my favorite Gun there's Oracles
in this one too is Oracles on this one
but the Relic hold cleans yeah
the yeah ready so so no the flag's here
the flag's right
here remember the boss spawns in three
different positions up top Center cuz I
really want
to cuz it's so good with the clip I
don't think
that you think we could push him off
with With Grenades shoulder charge
bung's
watching the oracles the oracles don't
needan as much but if you don't kill the
oracles it marks you plus it spots
minur it might might SP wav if you
might all right I really don't use
shotguns so I'm putting this F verdict
in my
gun def especially got a good roll we
don't know what R did you get Auto host
the ring and onew
punch yeah I got a final verdict with
unrelenting and vorpal
weapon you got vpal yeah vorpal weapon
and unrelenting on a found
verdict nice I found Precision you know
what this is a boss phase we should do
Anarchy uh it is agressive agressive he
or the ground I mean he in the air
though you put one on him and one on the
ground yeah yeah you can do it because
because what's his name's up off the
ground too in the uh in the Crypt that
that dude's on the ground too I'm
sticking with Zeno Zeno's been my
friend all right I'll rock Zeno until
next round yeah all right let's go try
what try all let's go what try we got
we'll see how it
goes I remember putting a shield here
this is all I remember
yeah
too there
are
yeah I got two over here there's three
on Three's on the
right
one the boss just melted three boss melt
melted me
too do they have to be in order now yes
they have to be in
order
don't you got to shoot
him there you
go he he he teleports to that one over
there
remember that little circle over there
you'll stop his
teleport on the
damage all right all right let you the
the ra accuser has to do it I think I'm
going to put Anarchy on him just because
I can do the relics guys we don't need
to do the oracles cuz he can cleanse
us we all stand together right isn't
that
correct come get
me oh where are you I can't
hear right behind
you thought he was going to go
not my bad you guys my headset it keeps
going on
off my
head my headset's just turning off for
no reason the the W Xbox W one yeah it's
just turning off for no reason it's
bugging it's bugging crazy right now
yeah I had that issue I I literally had
so do do do I shoot the beam at him with
the Relic or do I or do uh I just go
where he's supposed to teleport the
charged one goes towards the boss that's
what I remember but yeah when you get
your super you let us know you about to
shoot him so we can get ready for DPS
shoot him with the Relic we all DPS if
you go stand in the white circle with
the Relic and just do the cleans so the
shield he won't teleport the DPS
you got the
bubble all right I'll be The
Relic why you trying to take my shine
man I you can I'll switch to Divinity I
don't care e that's yeah I'll switch to
Divinity that's fine there you go there
you go yeah yeah do Divinity yeah yeah
like that we about that I remember
always being the shield guy I
love y ready yeah God I don't have to be
I got actually put in some work that's
what I'm saying that's why he's like
take my shot no no no have your shot
that's we about oracles or no yeah let's
are we doing okay [__] oracles we're all
going to stand on one side and
M put a down I put a bubble in the
back let me know when you're going to
shoot bubble going
here all yo get getting up in the thing
so you get my mark all right I'm
shooting
now Mark I'm still
marked yeah I was still Mark I was still
Mark we a get Clans nobody CL they might
they might have took that away I got
Clans oh took the hustle I got cleansed
I got cleansed they took the hustle I L
I literally just I had the thing up
overall I got
cleansed you got cleansed yeah I
got
let's try it one more time and
if if it doesn't happen then we'll just
we'll have to do the oracles
too he I'm just going to say sleeper did
48,000 for one shot I did one shot on
him yeah cuz he's got that the crit
spot so maybe something mhm I'll look at
my damage when it's my
turn
here do it now get out of the bubble
maybe it's it's glitching in the bubble
maybe it's the bubble messing with it
yeah see I'm good now no I'm still
marked yeah it's I'm still still I'm
still marked yeah I think the bubble
might be messing with it though cuz the
first when I had the Relic that first
time it cleansed everyone we we we kep
going yeah I think you got to cleanse
first then then do it Hunters can't
cleanse they dirty they
dirty nasty filthy you know what's funny
T said that with the most serious voice
like
yo I'm dead said H this kid cleanse
I'm
do the clear before
po yeah do the we go get we'll say we'll
see if it works we'll officially
see try to knock him down first and then
cleanse
us I'm not charged yet no you have to
have you have to have it up when he does
it that's what it is
no yet now I have it now look I'm I'm
cing y'all
I think you have to have it up before he
does the attack there no no never had to
have it up before he did the attack ever
but but all I'm saying is when I did it
that first time something happened
because when we you when did you wait
wait when did you do it the first time
I'm the only one that's ever held The
Relic no I held the Relic one time no
you didn't I have round I have a stream
I had it the I had it the first round I
had every did whatever round I he did
have it one time I remember I don't know
which round it was but he did have it
one time we only did three he had it one
time I do remember I do remember all
right y go ahead do warlock can't do I
mean you didn't
know up time I'm
dead I'm dead ready I mean put I'll grab
it I'll grab it I mean it's like I said
it's
not it's worth trying where
is take it take
it all right everyone get near
me oh hold up when when did he dides he
do it so I know want to do
it I'm not negated everybody I'm not neg
now I'm now I'm when is he I I I didn't
have it up when it now do it now do it
nowk no I think he's got no when when is
the the thing when he actually does the
attack I don't know the like the sign he
he does it whenever the Oracle got
killed no I mean like is there like a
sound kill oracles bro I don't think
it's working tell you I think they took
that away I don't think they did cuz I'm
telling you I did it that one time and I
cleansed everyone but you're literally
cleansing everybody and I
think I think you I think you have to
have that Shield up when he does it like
not but after he does it whatever yall
want to try whatever yall want to try
how do you cleanse that's what I'm you
just hold the left trigger that's all I
I I I didn't have it up when he did the
attack doesn't matter but go ahead and
pick up the Oracle I mean uh
oh my God like why are you acting so
extra over this like like we're just all
we're doing is just discussing something
and you being so extra budes happy
everybody I'm just
sayead I mean if it doesn't work it
doesn't work but but damn man I'm not
I'm good hey you don't sound
good temperature
get over here
R I think what we have to do guys I
think we have to stay in the back
here and shoot at the oracles from back
here and then just do it the way Forte
wants to
do I don't want to do it
anyway I think we have to stay in the
back I just want us to succeed
sir I'm
done have snipers here so we could
probably stay in the back and like uh
the uh the guy run an oracle just tries
to get on the plates and we all stay
back here you know and we can kind of we
can like we can see most of them from
here yeah you know you can one person
can stand here and you can see all the
way back through here you know see what
I'm talking about s this or you could
even stand in the other side there's one
three is over here and there's another
one over here yeah go back to uh there's
one right here two and three is over
here here you go Forte you should just
like just get oracles just focus on like
finding the oracles mhm I got you
T
what oh damn said you weren't worthy
yeah did say
that and you weren't worthy
either oh the cleanse wh is still in the
middle that's what I'm saying they put
the cleanse well down I thinking they
changed that [__] they may have changed
it
now what's the bubble for that do I
guess maybe just guard you I
guess like while you're sitting in the
thing yeah they probably Chang it
changed it changed
it ain't going be other
cheese in the middle though the C was in
the
middle
everybody get this part confused that's
what I'm saying everybody kept saying
that that you C through the bubble here
I'm like you don't uh attic and
I actually I actually think maybe
starting back here would probably be
better because we can see everything
from We're
run how many oracles are there three
there's
three I don't see none on left side I
see three one in the back I got
one where's two I have no clue I'm
shooting two probably that's three no
someone shot the wrong one yeah two on
the other
side I'm
cleansed you're
good
hang we miss the freaking oracles we can
all clean what's with this
bub lock you in yeah that's right I
forgot he locked you
in red shield how how we get out of that
I forget you shoot out of it just shoot
at
don't shoot
Rock now I'm said it's getting
spicy says Forte is gonna get the only
B why y'all be dropping two ra
BS
I'll go back where uh I used to be on
this side so I can get the left
side one I'll help you out adct I got
one I don't know where any of them other
are but I have one all get ready to
pleas I got
one that's it CLE all right I didn't get
there in time oh yeah everybody
everybody here I'm not the damn time
either how yo that's crazy that the
shield doesn't protect like that no
more what about the new old way where
everybody was standing
underground mhm oh no that was the
grenade knock him off the map never
mind
thinking maybe we can DPS from there
what we doing
y'all we
need someone's not killing all the
oracles well there's only two oracles
killed so who's on the left side I'll go
over there I I I was doing the way
someone's got to do the back someone's
got to do the I'm going to the back I'm
going to the back I'm just switching out
for machine gun
ammo and then we all meet on the right
side at that little Edge thing after you
kill all the kill all of them what side
the right side I'll work on the right
side because I have the shield no I'm
I'm talking about I was talking about
the damage phase that's what I was
talking about no I'm talking about the
oracles I'll work the right side for the
oracles and get the ones on the right
side but you guys got to get the ones on
the left there's no snipers right
there's no seems like there's no hob I
could just stand up here and shoot these
shits okay
all right let's
go I got one here two left three I got
two and
three want me to get this one 14k you
got it I got it he's got it down two and
three two got to jump down to see
it we got
Mark everybody the middle head to the
middle nobody jump in yet everybody get
here okay oh it disappeared somebody
jump in oh if you wait it'll still stay
up
for you got to if you stand right next
to we're wiping yeah yes yes
yesh yes yes
yes
so adct you doing those two left
ones yeah I'm out of
banners for the
thir you guys ready mhm yeah I'm ready
one I have two I have three I have
one
one I
died I don't know left okay I got you oh
yeah I got
you oh damn
I'm you are all the way in a weird
spot oh there you go oh get I'm shooting
the detained wall that is not the
way I can't shoot a single gun in no
somebody has to shoot you somebody has
to shoot
you
couldn't remember if we shoot out or we
got get shot
out my fault I'll pay the
tax
I got one two I got
three I have
three one down
I hope two is down I don't know three
nobody nobody killed two man nobody got
two I shot it it just didn't go down I
don't know why hit it with two
zenos I'm
detained man we just did this like like
six of them
like how we go for being to take six to
can't do in three like I know right we
just did six and why do you keep
Reviving people
Forte I did revive me
too he trying to Sol
it trying to keep the hope Al keep the
hope
alive I think we just have well is there
there's only three for this mhm oh okay
we
butchering got call out who has what all
but prepare be prepared to cleanse if
that [__] [__] up everybody need
to we can still still do D do it yeah we
yeah that's true we got to be better
with I'm going stay over there that's
what I'm doing add got it
cover yeah there's no snipers or
anything there's no
snipers
I got
three who has one and two one got one
get that one right there tag
two three get three there you
go all right everybody let over
here I'm standing in it I'm standing in
it oh t god
damn
they detain me I can't do DPS that
sucks there's no way shoot me out of the
T I can't do anything yeah I'm
dead did he teleport
again all right
more
looking at oracles one's over here I got
two I got
one
cl I got one need to CL there's two I
got
two oh I see three I see three I got
it now I'm marked for negation all right
going to the
side all right everybody over here yall
ready yeah
all right shooting
him behind
y i i there was no well or anything down
yeah I'm going to switch to well I'm
going to switch the well help
out well will force all
crits yeah and then I'm going to do um
Luna
factions oh yall still going
waste of time I can get I get somebody
oh no we
got a second I got to switch
out we definitely
has top everybody should switch to
sleeper
yeah
beat yeah beat it already once so
sleeper was mov doing that work for you
sleeper was doing pretty good yeah all
right I'm going to switch through that
let me second switch
up did a bon just already quit no there
he
is
I
okay now I got to get
sleep
big what what up boys [__]
raid my God y'all still doing that
yeah
that's fun right what's good with you
you good I'm good man just beat the
Destroy All
Humans for the records up you're on
stream so just hot
Micon abon is still on the oracles
on
YouTube oh
[__] I don't even know you did that hold
on about to watch yall fail and live D
and make fun we've been failing for
we've been failing for like four hours
so yeah yeah we been failing for a
minute I see you right now live a lot of
entertainment lot of entertainment can
they hear me yeah they can yes I I don't
I don't ask
permission are you guys ready to start
no no
no damn I'm almost broke I'm so broke
math class math
class I mean there are I got you up I'm
watch you ton of places where you could
just sit oh my god with this
again he said oh my god notice no notice
when we beat that last encounter were
you up in one of those places will stop
it like and you're not allowing me to do
it he said you're not allowing
me taking away my taking away
Myers stopping your sh are you guys
ready look where I found look at how
safe this place is look at it it's like
a little just like a like a little
bed a year and a half yo yeah you can so
you you can hit him from any part of the
map well pretty much well the the two
middle parts go okay but we a what so we
going to act like he don't teleport
everywhere okay I got
oracles you mean the three oracles that
we should have no issues with cuz we did
six a minute ago yeah we
shouldn't all right for another time
maybe oh God love anyway let's go hold
on hold on hold on
I'm probably gonna have to actually
leave in not that long I'm just
realizing let's go let's go let's go
let's go let's
go I'm ready all right start
it one two get three s three's on the
sakase
guess they're all on that
side oh
[__]
one oh my God I got it I got it I got
it all right get up
here
where he
go oh well he he still got the thing up
you got to break the thing yeah I got I
I got he got to recharge his shield he
put the shield down I saw it on the
floor it's
all Mark for
Megaton yes a
rap
you if you hit him with the blast what
you doing I was try okay I got I got two
yeah I
think from the of the I think we're
supposed to go to the red part cuz
that's canceling where he's going anyway
so we might as well go
to I'm supposed to go to that part and
cancel we all might as well go there
shouldn't right
you no he he he can get Arro over there
so he's supposed to hit him with the
thing and go to where he's teleporting
and and Bubble Up oh so he can never
teleport okay right so we extended
damage phase and he can pull AR yeah so
he ain't looking at us and we drop well
bubble all right let's go we don't have
grab we just don't grab banners anymore
okay I put the I put the banner down
flag flag guess we not grabbing the
flag I got two flag
challenge yeah we doing a challenge we
got one and three no flag three I got
two 10
yeah not
cleansed not
cleansed
just
watch well why do you keep Reviving
[Music]
us something dark
side
over dude over here saying he can't stay
long he Reviving us make it go off
another 10 15 I actually just found out
I can stay a little longer than I
thought like a little bit longer it's
green something something something r
Reb
scum Rebel scum Rebel
scum it's so hot out it's hot bro it's
hot we no longer doing the nonr banner
challenge
mode are you guys ready squash that real
quick
get that uh super meter back get it
back okay I got
three I got one I got
two one two Forte wasn't
one Forte hit the wrong one no no Forte
did not it said it said heard's voice it
said Forte killed someone one and then
it said you've been marked that means
you killed the wrong
one why I cannot help that it's just
look I can't help it I can't help it's
telling on you it's just facts it didn't
tell on me it didn't tell on me I got a
stream let's look at the scoreboard
let's look at this scoreboard let's look
at the score
board score y I love I love the here
right now oh yeah bro
raids exactly s Ked it too soon because
I had it said for on my screen on my SC
I'm looking at it right now it says
Forte killed it and then the Mark showed
up right after you for outnumber getting
the wrong
number you're
known is that your ammo
is he said you've been
known listen to I'm done I'm done
[Laughter]
this man go sit here want to like it's
okay you got the oh uh get get two s
right there yep
one I guess I'll get both of them you
got to get both challenge I I got one oh
what happened
there Mar yeah that was me I assumed
Sinister had that I had to get
two
how long yall been at this four
hours just enough to be be still be
having fun yeah we don't stressful yet
of no return
[Laughter]
yet FRS I love it when we M prepared to
cleanse though we can save the whole run
everybody well that's everybody that's
true got to all get there at the same
exact time but to be honest with you T
like if we're not doing if we're not
doing the damage phase consistently
we're not going to kill him either so we
ain't going to get to a damage phase if
we don't that is but we don't need a
cleans if we get the oracles it was your
[__] up you the
oracles the
tax pay the tax I paid the tax like
people are going to get there at the
same time to cleanse the
problem don't you love how me and Forte
just going at it now Taz and Forte
going I
got and we got excuses nobody I got one
I get there I get there every time I'm
just
saying focus focus focus focus focus
took out one got ham I got
two where's the third where's the third
where's the third there we go where are
you will again with this just do damage
in he's in a glitch spot really I'm just
on a
clip oh
man oh let me out somebody let me
out out he moved he's in the back
area I got detained where's the back
area what's going on with this Shield
nobody wants it I'm getting it got to
get it I think I think I think we might
have to do a reloc of who's got the
Relic that's just me though
like
abely all right all right I'll take the
Relic you take the left side you can
have it he said you can have it he said
you can have it because it ain't got
nothing to do because a got nothing to
do with the it's the other people that's
not doing their job what do you
mean a my f y'all ain't doing y'all job
go ahead you can have it look man I I
believe in you you could do this uh
no uhuh I mean I'll take the Relic I
don't care I'll take the Relic it's
sitting right there with your name on it
are you guys ready yeah
right I can actually do damage now to
the boss yeah you can do DPS
that one's over here
Forte I got I got that I got you get
that one I get two get to
yeah I had to do the whole left side
okay are you are you guys ready I'm
busting it
yep got the
wealth ritual of negation I got hit
yeah
to
3 all right oh [__] oh
ow oh I'm
detained why did he pick me telep
back I got two why did he pick
me can I be freed from that the
game shooting
to oh wow I do want to point out adct
does The Relic one time we do more
damage than we've ever done I do want to
point that out
hold because actually killed all the
freaking whaton it actually did it the
right but I do want to point out that
adct was the rain holder had the second
best and I would like to also say that
uh gaming Forte has
356,000 damage compared to the 49,000
that adct had the last time we did DPS I
just want to say so I I want to point
out that that's old [__] we talking
about new [__] I want I do want to point
out you just to you the one to just
tried to make old stuff new stuff that's
what you just Tred to do that oh my God
I'm let you live you guys ready
you you yes I'm ready with y'all
foolishness all right I'm picking it
up I got one but I'm dead oh [__] me
I got three got started before I could
get over there oh I got three I got
three I'm not going to be able to get
one oh my
God
Jes just
white down he going say just but he was
guessing
basically I died right on
one he no s died he couldn't get the
first one so it messed up the whole flow
I died on my way before the even oracles
popped
up you ain't believing it I just you
know just I'm just sitting here just
listening stop trying to make drama
where there is no drama I'm just
listening to everybody look look I I'm
just want to point out that if I didn't
call him out then you know that's saying
something I didn't call Sinister out
like I'm just saying man are you say are
you saying you have you have are you
saying you have more you nothing are you
saying you have
stand got four Dudes over there I'm over
here by
myself wait hold on you should have
superhero Powers now because I'm over
here with you oh now look look will and
you are over here yep we over here with
you now one two I got two I got one and
two no I got two you got three Sam one
and three I got three I got
three
take out
one
two getting ready to take him down
taking them
down why he not facing
us
ritual of
negation ad control get the ad control
get them
up I got smack by
uh I don't even know what numberers what
I know everybody's mod let's guess that
okay you got the first one right first
one's right where's the other
ones yo Taz is so fast on that he
run he just runs that [__] everybody
else [__] everybody else
fu you got
to you what's the difference if you're
the only one that goes through and then
it disappears then it doesn't
matter y'all need to be looking at the
screen you should be run no sir sir I am
on the complete opposite side of the map
from you you areally
already what crazy
hold on hold let me
you it says let me tell you let me tell
you what does let me tell you what is
doing right
now let me tell you
what literally Taz is literally hedging
his V every time he's literally getting
this close to that thing before it even
happen he's like oh said oh that thing
say he's
are you implying that he bathing in the
lake metac before everyone
else all right I'm starting it I'm
starting
it dude you're in there before I can
even fall
down is purifying himself and make Tac
before everyone
else one's down there one's down there
two's up here stairs
left I got one
I got two thank you thank you for coming
over
here one is down two's
down three's
down I'm waiting on you guys hurry up 3
2 1 hitting
them oh no not you didn't need to do
itet sorry about that
true
cuz I got the Lo of fa w we supposed to
get the guy with the shield a m orb so
that another
shot
no I always you could I
suppose all right watch
the three is that one one back I don't
know somebody shoot me out if we can I
have
three oh
sh one down oh killed me behind a pillar
one two call him out got it got it got
it got
it I'm stopping him from teleporting I
stopped him from teleporting like 4 I
thought it was only like I thought you
only two teleports two teleports and
then we go back to normal we just need
call outs and the oracles that's all the
only thing that's holding the oh look at
that DPS
man using sleeper now oh man oh W what
you using sleeper yeah look at that
Sinister DPS we
got
Divinity anybody got I'll use Divinity I
oh we wasn't using oh weren using I'll
put I'll put on
Divinity let's focus
fellas thank you for joining me on the
left again you know even though people
talk [__] and then
leave I had it too I was like where's
One where's two where's One where's two
picking it up Pi it oh no one said
anything I see two I see
three just white for got to get ammo
just where's one
one who has one I don't just white
Forte's got to get ammo just white okay
oh down down you know we struggling but
I'm enjoying this I really am like oh
I'm definitely in
tant oh my God it's so nice having four
in here and especially Taz because now
it's not just on addict like I'm not the
only one that gets jumped up for
everything like other people start drama
and it's not me so it's always nice like
it's nice that be part I could just
enjoy the drama CU you can't enjoy the
drama if you're part of the drama but
you can definitely enjoy the drama if
you're not part of the
drama you're hilarious you guys ready
yeah three no okay calm down I didn't
pick it up you were scouting though did
did you hear me count
too picking up now you can start it
now one I got one I have
two I got three I
think yeah I got
three I got
one got
it two
taking him down in three two
one oh my God why did it push me off the
push you off
yeah that was a
terrible we lost you on that DPS yeah
I might still be able to get a
few still
something oh what the
hell the hell me thank you
sir I got
three I'm going to die yo it's nuts in
there bro three's in the back
left back
here got one I think one is this three
get three yeah get three yeah back here
back here is
three got it there you
go little bit of
luck Jesus yo it's nuts bro the ads all
right well it's the ads because when you
do that when you hold them in place it
finds the
minur
yeah it's a
w yeah whenever you hold them in place
let's just let's just do three and then
uh let's just do three and then
reset the initial one and two delays and
then reset I'm thinking two well I I
wouldn't even delay them I would just
but we're not doing a whole lot of
damage if you don't delay him you might
do
10% delay him only once and then
everybody go yeah just do it once cuz
you get a I actually still I'm delay I'm
delaying DPS the thing is though I'm
delaying him like like four times before
the oracles even
start I'm I'm telling you two is fine
well well you're no yeah you're just
saying you're just finding a bunch of
extra minors and it's hard to get to the
Oracle all right then we'll just delay
once I I I don't I'm just saying just to
do the most damage no two I said two I
said two is fine two is fine okay then
one we we'll we'll try two and if it's
two over one we'll go to one you know
this coming from the guy who doesn't
have to cross the map to get to his
oracles to see his oracles this coming
from the guy that has to literally go
around the whole map and stop from T DPS
we got AC cross the
map I got three I don't even see where
one is one's over there where will is
two's at the staircase I'll go get two
I'll get
one one's dead two's down okay I get
ready to to go three's down DPS
now oh you over there I can't
shoot over there where are you oh oh
he's over there're right here yeah that
was
bad I'm
frozen I don't know if you guys can get
me from there
yeah can you guys get me he
moved a it's too late it's fine that
that was just bad luck he froze me in
the behind that
pilling and I didn't know he faces me if
I hit him
either I have
two I have two who has
one I don't know where it is I got one I
got one I got one oh
God two's
down just watch
it was
me see what I mean about getting to your
area late and we don't know where the
hell the oracles
are I we didn't even do two though we
only did
one see how that
work I was completely out of position
DPS all right tell me when you guys are
ready picking up
now I got one I see two and I got
three one right here you want to get one
stair that's one right here's one that's
one yeah that's is this two over here
that's two yeah all right there one
down who has one I got it I got it one's
down one's down I don't hear you when
you call out well I I didn't see like at
the I figured you looked at the bottom
left I didn't get to do it he need to do
it I just don't hear you like I don't
know if it's your mic or
not hear not hearing him
no well that's a
problem not hear at least they didn't
hear him there did anybody else hear I
can hear everyone
I we got to fix the mic issue I I mean I
I hear everyone like is it my mic
like I just didn't hear you now I hear
you I just didn't hear you call out when
you had it yeah you didn't
say I could I should just start watching
The Kill feed but sometimes it moves
quick if other things are getting
killed okay you guys ready just just
blame don't worry about it just blame
that's fine we just go I don't care
blame one is on the left I have it I got
three I got got
two is this two two that's two right
there at
stairs one's dead two two's
dead three's
Dead all right waiting a couple seconds
hitting
him shoot me shoot
me
where'd he go where'd he go somebody
shooting Divinity in the a for no reason
well I'm trying to get ad out of the
thing oh
okay yeah everyone's got to shoot
me huh where'd he go I wonder it's it's
fine it's fine it's fine look for the
oracles oh I wiped Mo it's
white
yeah tell them how you feel 14 tell them
how you
feel I feel anyway that's what they said
in the
chat
[Music]
oh messy
IB te will be running later
tonight BT might have a better time than
the
a they got all the they know everything
stairs I got three
I'm going over there to
run I got two I got
three one two one's down
three waiting a couple
seconds taking them down
now
how am I taking
like what happened reset
reset your supers clear the ads I'm
stuck somebody shoot me out yeah
alls anybody somebody shoot him out take
him
out
reset
I got
one I got one I one who's got
two I got three it's all right side on
the two and one we prepared to clear if
we don't know we got
two
right right there two hit two hit it it
is hit the third get
three all right
way over here and I'm not going to be
able to C and I came straight
there that's why I say you got to wait
you got to wait Taz or the cleans cuz
yeah they can't get there you got about
5 to 10 seconds before that cleanse
before that thing will kill you yeah
once your mark you got to wait yeah cuz
I K I literally came from killing that
Oracle from the stairs and had to run
all the way over there
and that's cool that's cool we got it
we'll get
it
can I check something really quick yeah
is it a glitch
no and what if we all use outr
perfected yeah you know what let's do
that doesn't work anymore without the um
after pass vacations R be you guys ready
on hold on hold on hold on
try I want to try that I want to see
what the DPS do without sleeper and my
my oven
joint I'm with you I'm gonna do it with
you I don't think it I don't think it's
gonna unless the whole
team I'm just talking about when because
what's happening with sleeper is I'm
running out of the full clip you know
what I'm saying so at least I was going
to try about thread a needle with v and
see since Len's got buffed and then have
um outbreak perfected for extra DPS one
spot heavy runs up the boss back
on I got one with boss back for and
clown you guys
ready okay going
now everyone's ready right
no you could go
ahead I have one I got two I got three
[__] you
boss one's dead two's
down waiting a couple
seconds hitting
them
go oh he went back in the
wall that's fine
just get back to positions yeah just get
ready for uh wait for the
Thing Two
by I got three right I think
who has one I got one I got two who has
three I got three right
okay one down two
down get over here by me get over here
by
me coming will you got to use two one
taking him
down
keep shooting I'm going to cancel this
one God I'm going to die all right now
take off take off now take
off we I little too
greedy what would you guys die I don't
know the ads we I think one of those
things blew up in his well and we
couldn't tell the difference
oh great now I got to sit here and wait
for this to kill
me that was a good run though that was a
good
run we're starting to get more and more
I think we could do one delay I really
do I think we could do one delay easy oh
threaded needle is what it do I don't
even need sleeper I got 22 in the clip
let's
go and I miss shots that's great what
you use it
TZ you just sleeping straight up I've
used the like like six
banners you guys ready or oh will are
you
ready
yep
one
three all right I got two over
here this is three yeah
yeah destroyed
one two down two down okay
yeah freze down but I'm going to
die go get him someone go get him real
quick someone go get him real quick I'm
going to wait a couple more seconds 3 2
1 I'm hitting
him
I
died it's hard in that back area man
it's no
joke all right go ahead and move move
move
move what did I die
from I can't get
out
got killed from a menar in the back I
got
you I'm locked in the
middle I have two I got
one we got to do a just find the third
find the third one ready for ready for
clan oh mer no go to Clans oh sorry wait
wait wait wait wait wait oh somebody in
my fault my fault there it is I got it
my fault screen I got it it's fine no I
died I got
it it's fine that was a bad run anyway s
died we lost a lot of
[Music]
DPS I feel that like after the first DPS
phase though there's so much ads like we
got with cl well they they they only
spawn like this because holding it right
but I feel like once we finish like it's
crazy I'm I mean that's the first time
I've held him
once no I'm not saying not to hold him
I'm just saying we got to do a a better
job once it come
out I'm rning
te
after
ground yep B I'm bottom tree okay throw
the
smoke so we Mo you guys ready yeah
yeah help us get out of this get out of
here M I'm barely surviving especially
now that I'm
not I have
three I'm going over to the left
side tell me we one or two or down
one's down oh my God I'm dead how do you
keep Downy get someone get
him where's the
third I have third but nobody said
nobody said two they did say two this
time I heard it I didn't say I didn't
hear
it
why I'm not here in attic for some I
didn't do it that wasn't me he said it
wasn't him
oh no I was saying wees too that's what
I saying if they finish challenge mode
you know come
back finish challenge mode we had easier
time getting this done you know me to
fish out this is for 24 hours you gotta
it don't get turned off until
tomorrow after that when I'm done paying
them for a while
you ain't
done say that you
a't I
got one I got
one
three took it one's
gone
two's oh my
god oh s grabbed it yeah I'm dead I'm
dead we're all dead who didn't get the
the the
thing with the um Oracle
yeah oh think anybody
found yeah don't feel like no one was
killed on each someone messed up the
order so it's the
order I'm out of
Bann
side one and
two one this is one right here yeah this
is
two the attic you get two get
one one's dead two's down come with me
S ow ow hey bu get nobody got
three want to die I don't think any got
three I got that
time we're regressing yeah like this is
this this is ridiculous guys come on
man I guess I'll go back it just comes
down to Oracle call outs really mhm no
one and two was called out
one and two but nobody called out three
it's cuz three didn't get killed so how
you go count three oh someone messed up
the order then no no nobody killed the
third one I don't think no there's three
Oracle kills three yeah it's the order
someone messed up the order it could it
could have happened it could we could
have killed it
late
what I don't know let finish this
right very
dangerous I have
one I got
three I got
two one's
dead
choose what the hell that's not me he
didn't kill it yeah I don't know why the
[__] it didn't die I killed it it just
didn't
register
n regression
regression when your guns don't work
like they used to be
don't start it
yet what you switch
too oh I just put a grenade
launcher one is I have
two I got
three one is down two is
down three is
down all righty I got the first one oh
SC hitting it down now sorry I just did
it soon as I got there D we able to save
it yeah I didn't use
it
oh all right hit a couple more times and
move out move
out I'm getting tagged from behind like
crazy all out I see three three's on the
uh the staircase one's Sinister three's
with the staircase
the other one has to be on the left I
got to see just to keep alive shit's
crazy all right what number is this
one there's two people here now guys
guys guys get them come on yeah no one's
no one's saying anything no one's
calling yeah
Co soon as you see one I mean you have
to look around for I had one but no one
I I assumed it was first because no one
was destroying any on the other ones I I
just said I was going to the third one
and I went to the third one so I was
just waiting on one and two so it was
the one that sin had then it was mine
and then it was the third
one just say I'm so and so and I'm
killing this
one my name is so and
so and I'm killing
this [__] we had a meeting or
something
I got I got there late so I asked which
one is this one I know yall heard me say
that I didn't know to be honest two I'm
on
three I don't see
any there's one over there with
Cog I Cog kill that one right there your
left that
one kill s kill
yours killing mine
good killing it taking down yeah okay
going to delay
him I'm not delaying him
anymore oh that should all right go go
go get out
I'm locked in I'm getting
jumped never mind I killed everything
even know I was
dead one's here over two there here all
right I'll get one I'll get one you move
to else I got one oh no I have two I
have two I got three I got three I got
okay okay okay we're good we're good
we're good go ahead and Kill Them All go
ahead who's got one no sin has it do it
s one down two's
down oh [__] s there we go somebody
get C up the well
yeah oh no you guys are on the wrong one
it doesn't matter you guys messed up the
order you messed up the
order what happened what you messed up
the order one was sin two was you and
three was uh t I know I we no we got all
that that was we just we just went to
the wrong place we get everything shoot
it shoot it shoot
it it's reloading because ad died
oh got
it adct why'd you die
what oh now good you got well I
got yeah look for oracles I got
oh I two who has I got one one's down
who has
two I'm
frozen three's down three's down three
down yeah we did we did we did
it
detain
there's no way to break from the
detain I got killed by the
ads just
why what is
doing Wast of time you refuse to wait
refusing to
wait oh now you want to
c i I didn't need to I didn't need
the I just jumped in the circle just
jump in the circle now you want
the PS it's a lot it's a lot easier to
do it when one person isn't running
there like Speedy Gonzalez before
everybody else I'm I'm playing a slow
ass bro I know
hun know Hunter about I know you Ain
talking about how a Titan is slow in
this game and it's probably the F
because all you got to do is go
invisible run straight
[Laughter]
line a lot of lot of Hunter and Titans
it's it's all right I'm starting it
ready there's a difference yeah we're
ready but we fall apart is after the
first DPS
all you got to do is do get damn grenade
right
back two's here two's here Focus boys
Focus one is here I have one I have
three one down two's
down three's down all right waiting a
couple seconds taking them down
now we don't have to go anywhere cuz
this is where he's
teleporting get me
out
BBE somebody can't get him out all right
move move get
out
all right I'm out oh [__] I'm the T so
when you're in Japan there's nothing you
can do to get out I got you out oh
thanks ad you have a
yeah I see
two how am
I I see
one I got help
Deads man have three people went down at
the exact same moment
which one is this s we got it though
take it down I went down too it's the
minotaurs just get out guys got it I
can't I I killed two of them but I mean
there's just so many of them so many
yeah what sucks is we're in a
predicament where it's like do we do DPS
to the boss or we or do we add
clear actually cuz we're CH we have we
have to choose guns to do DPS but the
ads are [__] us up too so
what are you using
will yeah Will what are you
using look the quietness what's up what
are you using I'm using uh sniper and
sleeper simulate and a vision of
Confluence what the hell DPS did you
just do yeah you had DPS oh no I didn't
have heavy oh oh because somebody prob
started it
without yeah I'm having cuz I'm gonna
have to go very soon I said four times
is
every it's fine I'm trying to like do
two things at once two step I have three
left I got
one I have
three one one's
down that steps was that steps no nobody
got it nobody got
it I mean you guys are over there your
position I know I nobody's I call out
one somebody's got to just call out the
other one that's it you just got to say
I'm so and so said to I he didn't get it
though I was dead I told I got you died
I that was you who died screen if you
still have issues hearing like hearing
people you know you can turn person up
individually in the party I think I did
hear
uh adct up okay I'm hearing him better
now I just didn't know uh I know
Sinister was
dead all right you guys ready yep yeah
man
I got one will has two and three is over
here I have three so you get
two yeah no one got
one that's bad who called it out this is
bad who's calling it out though like if
you say you have one ad that's you got
to get one I didn't say I had one I
thought you said you saw one I thought
you said you saw one we had two and
three where me and adct were standing I
had I was with you I was with you I had
three call out we I I don't know if
we're just not hearing each other no I
can hear for you all so when you say
when you see one you take that one
whoever sees it take it just I I I'm
trying to figure out why we're having an
issue I'mma blame right
side whoever was the Oracle keeper for
right side so you blame Forte is that
what you try to
[Music]
do one's over here
take take
one
I don't see any I don't see any who sees
others who sees others call them out
call them out nobody sees them nobody
sees them nobody's calling out they're
all
over I got it I got it I got it I got it
I got it I we got it yeah good starting
it three two one
now
all right go Ahad take off take
off okay I'm stuck I'm stuck I don't
have anything to get
him you guys got
SHO
I got three all right I have three no I
have three go get go get another one I
got you s give me a second I got one I I
got two all right all right so attic
take one for get ready on
two one's down is one down yes one's
down down oh my
God three's down three's
down all right everyone over where he
is
I don't got well shooting it now I have
it I have
it someone shoot me shoot me shoot me
everyone shoot
me there we
go hit the damn wall no
Divinity how I got in a
well go and take off take off take
off then put my dead body next to the
boss
Mark the DPS was horrible three it's all
on the right it doesn't matter dud look
at that DPS we lost three people I don't
have a
token we're dead just
just
we probably what you think just do we
really anybody check anti
barrier like can we shoot him with anti
barrier weapons
beforehand I'm pretty sure they would
have thought about that that that
barrier is probably not considered an
actual barrier it's considered a
mechanic that can't be
shot I have one I have one will has one
look for two and three for two and three
shout about when you have I I got three
okay all right all right here we
go
one is
down two two is down three is
down get ready for
DPS Mar hitting
him why am I cuz you probably stepped in
the
pool
oh
I'mma delay him again but he's it's a
really bad part to get him over
here run run get out get out get out I'm
I'm stuck I'm stuck someone shoot
me where are you I'm over
here oh I have three I'm stuck in the
back and this guy's meleeing me in my
face I can get two three we need there's
three Minotaur back here Nova bomb
please who has
one I know you didn't res me in this
chaos I got one who has
one that was that was
three you said it I said I said I have
two and three I said I have two and
three got to have more
communication I mean I'm scream is
communicating like a mother
like he this out like
a what's going I think I only have like
one or two more runs than me guys just
cuz I'm going to have to go
[__] got to be somewhere at eight takes
an hour to get there time to cancel
plan you know how many times I fall out
of work not be
happy unless you got to take one for the
team oh my trying to destroy this man
B
got to take one for the ra
team I see three I'm going to get three
three is on the stairs three is on the
stairs somebody get one one's over here
one's over here I got one okay you take
it you take
it
one get two s
trying think I got it take it well got
it I'm dead
anyway oh I'll get S I'll get s
ready never mind you you want to take my
spot I just said never
mind you I di I died
too going be a bad
DPS chaos in the
back oh my God look at that we can't
even jump
away take my spot 14 I want you to
experience I need help what we going
through
he moved he moved he moved I'm
froz oh my God
GS just white I I don't know all
right I want you to take that back left
and see the chaos that's going on back
there what part you got on the right
I'll take your
spot
okay [__] what part you got on the
right where you at I'm just rolling on
the right R2 all right this might be the
last one guys all right that's cool I'm
so
sorry
Life Life Is Life bang these plans were
made quite a while ago I didn't realize
they lined up on the same before I knew
what day the raid
was you good
bro on the steps two all of them are on
left of course when I put him over there
then they want to put it all on me I got
two all right who has one and
three I have one two and
three someone take
one one's down two ptic and then and the
back
one got
it all right about to take him 3 two
1 guys what
happened ritual ination I'm locked touch
the P oh I just got nuked in the well
that's
crazy I think I took like the whole
front of that entire attack
somebody using
Nova no somebody all right get out of
here blocking my shots now yeah death
ringer who's using death ringer I had
the most DPS the last two rounds agent
ordinate oh [__] behind us there's no
bubble
awesome I'm I'm stuck I'm
stuck I have two I don't think it's
going to
matter who has one
three I got lucky one I got two where's
the third where's the third got
it no
you're that's
it let me guess who took this
[Laughter]
already all right guys I have R all
right
later have a good one brother thank you
guys huh what did you say
yeah oh they don't care we're seeing a
movie we're going to a drive-in my my
wife wants classic oh classic can't
hardly
wait you got take the Xbox hook it up to
your phone you get you play Xbox while
she's looking up do we have a person we
have a person on deck that can come in
oh
I was G say take like 20
minutes sound real good yeah break 20
minute break find next person me back
yeah meet back at I will be back I will
be back on later tonight I ain't going
I'm stay in the party I'm stay I still
want to get I'll be
back stay in the party y f later guys
all right bro
the
back
was
for
oh you guys still
there I'm g go and end the stream you
guys like